we're so close to election day very
close less than a week
and then everyone's gonna go out and
cast their ballots and uh then we're
gonna wait a couple days for them to
count the votes and then figure out what
happened because everyone's gonna get
really mad I imagine but uh I think
everyone will get mad to a certain
degree because a lot of people on the
right of me mad is taking so long to
count votes in certain States and the
left is gonna be mad because all the
projections right now show that it's not
just going to be a red wave it's going
to be a red great flood tsunami doesn't
doesn't really get to how crazy it's
supposed to be based on these
projections but I'll tell you don't
count all your chickens before they
hatch you never know what's going to
happen but right now the big news is
that Joe Biden has been campaigning in
safe blue districts and you have to
wonder why that is it's because their
internal polling is likely so bad they
know they're going to lose in places
they should not be losing Joe Biden went
to Miami-Dade he went to Miami this is
an urban center this is a city
historically blue
a day later Republicans are leading in
early voting that's amazing they're even
saying DeSantis might win Miami that's
how bad it is now he's going to like New
Mexico desperately trying to convince
people that should be Democrats to vote
for him and why
well
Tudor Dixon was debating in Michigan she
brought up a story of a guy who said
that these sexualized books in schools
made him angry and the Democrats
wouldn't explain him what was going on
so he's vote Republican he wants to stop
Colbert goes on his show and says that
happened yeah right never happened and
even Google search it the Democrats
don't care about the issues that are
actually affecting voters they don't
care about gas prices so this is where
we end up with tremendous polling well
Joe Biden went out and gave a speech the
other day where he basically said if
Republicans win it's the end of
democracy MSNBC had a similar segment
where this guy was like who knows if
journalists will even be legal after
Republicans win yeah yeah yeah okay
let's talk about all this stuff before
we get started my friends head over to
losingmymind.com I cannot believe we
actually got that URL it's I I searched
for it it was there but this is the link
to the new song coming out tomorrow
morning so if you're listening to this
show Friday or later the song is up go
to losing my mind.com to listen to the
new song by timcast genocide you're
gonna really love the Youtube video
um I was told that it's probably
controversial and we the whole thing
let's just say it's intended to piss off
the people that should be insulted and
critiqued and and yeah I don't I don't
want to give it all away but uh you can
see you know I'll say this from the the
album the song art you can clearly see
it's meant to mock News broadcasting so
you're really gonna love it so again
losing my mind.com don't forget to also
go to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly we have a
members only show coming up for you at
about 11 p.m tonight go to timcast.com
smash that join us button and then uh
share the show with your friends smash
the like button as well joining us to
talk about this and so much more is
Danielle de Souza Gill
thanks for having me Tim and Friends
Luke Ian this has been fun I got to see
Tim Poole play some pool so that was
really great so I'm glad to be here
absolutely who are you you want to
introduce yourself oh yes
um so yeah I'm an author I do a show
called counterculture on Epic Times
which I really like
um I tell young people that we have to
be The Counter Culture to the left's
insanity I've written two books one on
God one on abortion
um where I make pro-life arguments
countering pro-choice arguments talk
about how young people have been very
lost should seek relationship with God
talk about some Faith reasons science
things like that I was on the women for
Trump campaign really liked that I'm
very excited for Trump to make a big
comeback so um those are kind of the
main things right on thanks for joining
us should be fun thank you we also have
the super Freedom Fighter damn right uh
it was only a few months ago when the
corporate media was telling everyone and
fear-mongering about super spreader
events so we decided to make our own
version of that fear-mongering campaign
and make shirts that say freedom super
spreaders which is represented here on
my t-shirt it's a great way to start
conversations and by getting the shirt
you predominantly support me being here
you could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I'm here thanks for having me uh
hello everyone Ian Carlson here Danielle
happy to see you thanks for coming I'm
looking forward maybe we can dig into
your book on God a little bit maybe yeah
in the show we're talking about it
before the before the show start a
little bit sounds pretty interesting
talking about blending science and
religion I like that idea okay uh and
you evolve into a heated debate yes
let's roll what's happening Serge
I see you guys cheers let's enjoy the
show all right here's the big news
ladies and gentlemen in a tweet from
Kaylee mcinenny looks like Biden's visit
to Florida had an inverse effect quote
the number of Republicans voting in
Miami-Dade County a historically blue
stronghold surpassed Democrats on
Wednesday just one day after President
Joe Biden visited the county to campaign
I got to be honest it really does sound
like Biden showed up and they all were
like you want us to vote for what no no
no not happening here's where it gets
crazy
the data shows that Republicans are
leading in the early vote
now that's crazy because the early votes
always Democrat right now in Miami-Dade
early voting numbers 27 Republican 21
Democrat that means come election day
Miami-Dade County a blue City
historically Democrat stronghold may
actually vote Republican they may vote
for Ron DeSantis this is massive so when
everyone keeps saying Red Wave I'm like
okay
it's a dire sign they say for the
Democrats it sounds really really great
but ain't nothing gonna happen unless
you go out and vote and get your friends
to go vote and I'll put it this way if
you think you're going to win so you're
gonna do anything you will lose hands
down it'll happen
but if you rally everybody you know and
you go vote you could possibly win in
such a tremendous way the defeat would
be so crushing that no one would dare
run under the Democrat ticket ever again
because their policies are insane or at
the very least there would need to be a
very hard reformation and we'd see the
next two years of Democrats begging for
forgiveness because the policies they're
proposing are just they're just nuts
Republicans at the very least are
talking about gas prices so what do you
think's going on how do you feel about
this Miami stuff you're a Florida guy
right I love Florida I spend a lot of
time in Miami there's also a lot of
Cubans there a lot of Cubans like myself
who just came from communist regimes and
understand you know yeah Cubans like me
who went through a Communist Regime
right oh I see there were commas in that
sentence yeah right there were commas
that doesn't matter uh but but a lot of
people there realize you know especially
through the lockdowns especially with
how Florida handled covid that you know
you have to of course represent larger
ideas that represent you and it's it's
pretty clear that there was a party that
wants more lockdowns that wants more
restrictions that wants more taxes and
financially I think we're let's just be
honest here in a bit of a pickle I think
a lot of people in Miami realize that it
is fast it is booming there's a lot of
things going on but at the same time it
is a major city and I think a lot of
people are also feeling the Havoc of the
major failed policies by the Biden
Administration in Miami that's crazy
yeah I feel like if I was a liberal who
was running I wouldn't want Biden to
come down to campaign with me because
Biden's been so bad he's been such a
failure I think most people not just in
Florida but all over the country are
probably like oh my gosh everything was
great under Trump and now everything's
horrible under Biden so if I was a
Democrat running I would say here's what
I'm going to do different maybe from
both maybe this is like a new idea have
a new plan don't associate yourself with
Biden just do your separate campaigns
you're right there have been many
Democrats who have told them do not send
Joe Biden here like we can maybe win if
he doesn't show up and then he shows it
to Miami and look what happens a day
later Republicans overtake Democrats I
got I got to say I'm willing to bet
people went out saw him and then went no
way not happening and then immediately
went we're like I'm voting Republican
were there poll numbers before his
speech or yeah I mean these are early
vote numbers but that's what ABC is
reporting before he came Democrats were
leading in the early vote after he comes
a day later Republicans jump up there's
that like you know there's that reality
of like being in the presence of a rock
star when you go to a show when you're
actually there near them you start to
Vibe you like feel it and you start to
get into it because you're in the
presence of I imagine it works in the
opposite direction as well when you have
someone like Joe Biden who is maybe has
anti-charisma I don't know and it's like
Trump whenever he endorses candidates
they are immediately the person who gets
a nomination he helps them win whereas
Biden he goes towards a candidate
they're like oh my gosh now my campaign
is ruined please don't associate with me
and then plus it's like if you think
about it when Trump ran in 2016 then he
runs in 2020 his 2020 slogans were like
oh look here are all the great things
that happened since then let's have more
greatness more winning we're never tired
of winning but with Biden it's like you
can't say that because things have been
so bad so you basically have to say
um well I guess no real message like oh
Ukraine's the problem this is the
problem we can't really have any excuse
here we did have a little success but
like not really so there's no real
message of what they're gonna do there
is Maga Republicans are bad Maga
Republicans are evil that's what Joe
Biden did the other night he's like you
know these these these violence violence
got to stop and he's saying all this
nonsense about election deniers and I'm
like dude I'm glad he came out and said
all that stuff about how election
denying is wrong because when the
Republicans win in a red great flood to
come you know we'll get all the results
in on the ninth or whatever then we can
tell all of the Democrats who are
whining and crying about it hey hey no
election denying you know Biden says so
hey hey Biden said no election denying
and then what are they going to say
they're gonna they're still gonna deny
it yeah we'll see Abrams she's gonna of
course come out crying she's already she
was the first election denier she was
the one who said it was stolen last time
so I don't know what her plan is because
I think she's going to lose this time so
she's probably gonna say it was stolen
again which one does she say was stolen
like she runs for governor of Georgia
the polling is showing that she's gonna
lose and last time she ran she also lost
but kept saying it was stolen well the
Atlantic called her a superstar loser
I'm I'm really impressed the Atlantic
said this Democrats keep falling for
Superstar losers there's never been a
better time to lose an election okay I'm
just going to point out that when the
Atlantic is calling your candidates
losers before
I have to wonder is this like the media
is conspiring to make Republicans think
they're going to win so that they don't
turn out or something because turnout's
already really good for Republicans but
maybe this is what I was just saying
if every single person
who is independent and just hates the
Democrats sick of their BS and their
policies and every single conservative
went out and voted and voted against
Democrats be it Republican or whatever
the Democrats would lose so horribly
that they would be forced to reflect all
these big packs they'd come in and be
like why are we losing and then
someone's gonna be like I don't know
maybe it was the child's sex changes in
the Eight dollar gas and they'll go okay
and they're gonna have a reckoning and
it's gonna force them to course correct
and get off of this garbage so you're
saying the Dylan Mulvaney endorsement is
not going to help them I'm pretty sure
that something like that actually hurt
them substantially and that's why
Colbert came out and lied about that
guy's story so it was a guy from
Dearborn Michigan who told Tudor Dixon
that when he saw the explicit books in
the kids school he got really angry and
the Democrats ignore it or or support it
so he's voting Republican and then
Colbert's like never happened she made
it up that's that's a fake story because
he knows that if the American people
actually knew about books like this one
that Ian's got right here genderqueer
they they'd freak out and the only
reason parents did freak out is because
of the with the lockdown all the parents
were watching their kids in Zoom class
hearing the teacher talk about this
stuff and pull up these books yeah we
saw what happened in Loudoun County not
far away from here that even threatened
and scared to the FBI to the point where
they said that they're going to be
sending resources to investigate parents
that show up at teacher parent
conferences I mean this is the absurdity
of this Administration obviously they
have had failed policy after failed
policy after failed policies but these
are not failed policies these are
policies that I think a lot of people
are rushing through through the dead
vessel that is the Biden puppet
Administration and when you look at
these these policies they're not popular
they screw everyone over no one likes
them but at the end of the day they do
serve a purpose and there are a lot of
Corporations a lot of big banks that are
benefiting off of them but everyone else
is screwed now if only you know the
tally ban the drug traffickers and the
Ukrainian government could vote maybe
then we would have a totally different
political perspective but uh we don't
have that here in the United States we
have a pushback against what I see is
the great reset I just want to read this
one super chat I am says Red Wave is
such a generic term I've decri I decree
it to be called The Scarlet it surge
that's pretty good the Crimson Crush
I think it's dangerous to vote against
people in general like saying this
administration's so bad that I will vote
for the other thing because I think
that's what happened with the Nazis is
it was so bad after World War one that
people just wanted something different
so they grabbed the not the most
charismatic different one the Nazi eye I
I I agree to a certain extent I really
don't like the idea of voting against
Democrats or like voting against a
politician and so you know I sympathize
with what Dave Smith was saying that you
know you can't keep voting for the for
the lesser of two evils but my view
right now is like we're in the midterms
we're not voting for our president we're
looking at our our congressional
candidates and local Representatives
they like these are people that you can
go and talk to the local level these are
not the lesser of two evils often yeah
sometimes but but there's only a few
populist candidates there's some that
represent the will of the people but the
other Republicans are like I'll just do
what the Democrats are doing but just 10
years from now but that's why the
primaries were so important sorry oh no
I was just going to say to disagree with
you and that I think that that's also
how we defeated Hitler because we had to
Ally with Stalin because Hitler was such
a great threat so sometimes you have to
go with the lesser of two evils in order
to take on the greater evil in the end
so I do feel like it's it's okay if
Americans say oh my gosh my life sucks
like Biden is so bad this like this
economy is so bad I can't keep living
like this to vote for someone new
because a lot of the new candidates they
might not know them they might say I'm
not sure if I agree with everything they
say but I know I agree with this and
then try it and then you know see what
happens in 2024. we just saw the
libertarian candidate in Arizona drop
out and endorse Masters and so you know
Libertarians and conservatives have some
overlap but not a whole lot and as with
the mesos caucus now there's some when
it comes to like cultural issues so
there's actually kind of a big deal I
remember I was uh I remember who told me
this there was some Republicans were
saying the conservatives in like 2018
they were like they're saying some
conservatives had Libertarians need to
just you know sit down and vote
Republican and then I'm just thinking
like dude Libertarians don't like your
policies like they they're not you in a
different party they genuinely don't
but now the threat from Democrats is so
great to actually see the libertarian be
like you know actually I I would rather
have this guy because he at least has
some advancement in the cause of Freedom
as at least relative to the Democrats
who are authoritarian cultists well
there is some overlap right it's not
like it's just uh black and white here
because when it comes to the Second
Amendment when it comes to the first
amendment when it comes to the populist
individuals coming forward representing
those ideas in the battlefield of ideas
yes they absolutely do do deserve
support and there are a lot of
neoconservatives a lot of back crazy-ish
insane individuals inside of the
Republican party that are way worse than
some of the staunchest Liberals in our
party establishment that do create
massive amount of damage to our current
way of life to our freedoms and those
individuals do need to be called out so
a lot of the Libertarians are kind of
taking their popcorn and watching this
larger fight unfold within the
Republican party I want to dive into
this Atlantic story a little bit
Democrats keep falling for Superstar
losers there's has never been a better
time to lose an election
they're going to mention in the early
2000s the Japanese racehorse Haru urara
became something of an International
Celebrity not because of her prowess on
the track just the opposite her Haru had
never won a race she was famous for not
winning but for losing and the longer
her losing stretch her streak stretched
the more famous she grew she finished
her career with a perversely pristine
record zero wins 113 losses American
politics doesn't have anyone quite like
Haru urara but it does have beta
O'Rourke and Stacey Abrams the two
Democrats are among the country's best
known political figures better known
than almost any sitting Governor or U.S
senator and they have become so well
known not by winning big elections but
by losing them that right there I have
to just
seriously name a Democrat Governor the
average person if you if you said who's
beta or rocked I'm like oh yeah I've
heard of Beto I've heard of Stacy Abrams
it's like yeah they lost they're they
they're losers and I don't mean that in
the insult in in the pejorative I mean
quite literally they lose and the
Democrats prop them up have them on TV
shows cheer for them and celebrate them
when they can't win
yeah I don't know look maybe maybe I
really doubt they're gonna win but let
them try you know but there's which more
and then that crazy looking uh sociopath
guy from California yeah yeah
I mean the left was so obsessed with
beta O'Rourke putting him on the cover
of magazines acting like he's a Ronald
Reagan figure everyone's gonna back him
you know 49 out of 50 states type of
popularity he keeps losing Stacy Abrams
they acted like she was you know this
great Queen she kept showing up and like
even on when she went on The View
everyone acted like she was the greatest
person to ever grace their presence and
it's like at this point they're not
going to win their elections they
probably will end up though getting some
kind of show or ending up on CNN or the
view or MSNBC because they're kind of
just celebrities now but they're not
going to be politicians I just this
article is so brutal never before has
such small-scale loser dumb so often
been sufficient to achieve such a
large-scale stardom apart from Abrams
and O'Rourke there have also been other
examples in recent years Jamie Harrison
made an unsuccessful bid for the DNC
chairmanship then an unsuccessful bid to
unseat Lindsey Graham that a second bid
blah blah blah mg MJ Hager and a Texas
Democrat lost a close house race I just
wow the Atlantic's pissed I'm willing to
bet that right now with the polls that
are coming out in the projections of
Republicans winning 54 Senate seats
there are establishment Democrat
activists who are fuming like what is
wrong with the DNC that they cannot win
elections they prop up losers their
policies are insane it's supposed to be
the progressive liberal party but I
haven't seen real Progressive measures
proposed like fusion power I you know
real progress for Humanity I'm talking
about not like sending people to Grand
you need like we need to be recovering
the carbon from the atmosphere making
graphene new industry all these real
progress movements that's the demo
that's supposed to be the liberal part
of the puzzle that pushes for the new
things and they haven't I haven't seen
it Trump won the first race he ever ran
right that he the first thing he ever
ran for was President he wins no no he
ran a bunch of times for his presidency
and then oh he went to their form party
that's right uh no no he was at CPAC a
bunch of times lost a couple times as
well primaries yeah yeah I believe so
sure yeah I remember seeing him at CPAC
a couple years ago
I think he had like maybe teased and
passed like oh maybe one day I'll run
yeah for president um because people had
asked him that for years and I think
they only do it also in the 90s as well
no I think I think that he was he was
going to run for the Reform Party and
then didn't or something like that in
2000. here's a timeline history of
politics although I'm going to read to
this and then get back to you guys
um but yeah no I mean I think that the
left has this view of like what a
perfect candidate is and they're like Oh
Stacy Abrams is perfect like she's a
super educated black woman she's massive
like that's okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry it might need to be
censored on YouTube but then someone
like Beto they're like oh my gosh he's
great great this is what the new Texan
is like maybe if you're from Austin this
is like the new Texan who doesn't want
any of their weapons anymore and it's
like no one actually supports people
like that even like you were saying
maybe what do liberals want it's like
they're not going to vote for people
like them they probably prefer a
candidate like you were saying maybe
like a Bernie Sanders or someone who's
going to be more uh more leftist and in
actions or something but these people I
mean they're just like swamp creatures
they just want to be kind of famous TV
personalities Donald Trump uh the famous
TV personality was talking about running
uh for president all the way back until
1987. he did run under the Reform Party
in 2000 he teased it again in 2003 he
was in the polls in 2011 but then
decided not to run 2012 he endorsed
Romney and 2013 uh and then he runs
formed a presidential exploratory
committee and then so he did actually
run for the Reform Party yes in 2000.
um Obama was so charming and like well
loved and just like he's very empathic
he felt like he had good relationships
with his daughters his wife loves him it
seemed like a pretty genuine I don't
like how he got co-opted by the military
industrial complex went down that path
but people in the Democratic party now
are mimicking him they're trying to
Identity politics they want someone with
his skin color someone with his clothing
type like Beto wears the same similar
clothes as Obama he has that button-up
that he tucks in it even uh does this
when he talks with his hand then you got
like Pete bootage who's like
literally uh sounds like Obama when he
talks and you're like it's just like
they studied Obama when they were
younger obviously and I think that's why
Biden picked Kamala Harris he was like
oh when I was vice president I ran with
a black man so I'll pick a black woman
to run with me and then everything will
be great will be like a great dynamic
duo but of course Kamala Harris is like
the worst vice president we've ever had
she literally doesn't prepare for
anything she shows up to things to talk
and then her her words just go in this
Loop and she doesn't actually say words
right even though she has speech writers
yeah I I agree you know it's really
terrifying to see that Kamala Harris is
the vice president but it really is
entertaining to watch her talk in
circles like her brain doesn't work but
she's too young for that to be happening
you know what did she she said something
recently I can't remember what it was
but she was she said something about I
really love some I can't remember the
Venn diagrams Venn diagrams that was it
I really love Venn diagrams just the
circles don't you love like what lady
what is going on I think she made a
10-minute speech about that one uh that
one particular topic it's funny yeah
it's like watching you know comedy she
worked really hard though to get to the
positions where she's at though yeah hey
Venn diagrams are pretty cool but you've
got to think three-dimensionally you
know you're not flat on a paper you know
she was she was there with Willie Brown
you know in San Francisco and uh you
know she she wasn't thinking about being
just flat she Goofs around she seems
like she's afraid of saying the wrong
thing which I don't want someone that's
afraid in leadership is positions I
don't like it and having them literally
said that well I believe it was
literally said this they want a woman of
color in the office like they said we
need a person of color an office like
it's the the dumbest prerequisite for
someone in a leadership Authority you
need the best person and then we'll
figure out everything else if they're
that great they're going to create a
genre of people you know the people that
want to be like them people that are
proud to be like them but you need a
great person to instill that you can't
just force it in my opinion you can't
yeah I think they were whole things she
would be like the great successor to
Biden she would be the person who'd
really bring in all of the Charisma
because Biden's so old he's boring and
he was running as kind of like this
middle of the road person now that's not
what happened he obviously hasn't been
like that but Kamala Harris was supposed
to be like the really good politician so
it was actually really disappointing to
see how how bad she really is especially
since she's our our first woman vice
president of course they don't Define
what a woman is so they don't believe in
that word but I believe in that word and
so it's sad it's all they had they had
also gabbard but Tulsi wouldn't play
ball they were like we can't there's no
women of color on stage and told me
standing there with skin darker than
mine like a certain color you know of
melanin whatever the hell it is endorsed
Biden though she played yeah she played
the game but I mean she had
off the bat she she torched Kamala
Harris on stage metaphorically yeah
basically ended her potential to become
the president if she ever had it people
called her the Kamala killer afterwards
after that one moment on during the the
presidential debates where she just went
right at her and and this was an issue
that a lot of people knew about but were
afraid to talk about she brought it out
in the mainstream and there was no
denying the bigger truth that she busted
wide open on the main stage and that was
incredible so I give her full credit for
that yeah but what makes me think they
were good controller though she she was
she's anti-war yeah and she stood up for
the for for actual individuals who were
screwed over by the system actual
individuals who were uh you know you
know messed up by kamala's policies in
some of the worst most atrocious ways
and she stood up for those individuals
and people that had no voice so Props to
her they said we want a woman of color
as Tulsi was standing on stage like
there are no women of color on stage and
you're like what she's I mean I'm not
saying she's African American you know
she's like a Pacific Islander but it's
it's nonsense the person you you vote
for the person who's gonna do the do
right by the people of this country by
the country by its institutions and uh
and and without corruption in the bet in
institutions when they go wrong and so
that could be uh it could be Tulsi
gabbard it could be Pete booty judge it
could be whoever but um and I mean that
in a like identity sense I actually
don't think it could be people rejects
because I think he's corrupt I think
most the Democrats are and I think what
we've seen over the past few years is
that
if you're paying attention to what's
going on in politics you'd be like I
cannot support Democrats like even for
Tulsi Tulsi gabbard to have endorsed
Biden to me it's kind of like are you
serious dude like Tulsi is anti-war
she's anti-intervention she knows Biden
is a warmonger and she endorsed him
maybe you know I guess 4D chess or
something I think she had TDS at the
time she was so upset and dislike of
trump
but she also had the option of Bernie
but but we're hearing news reports that
Bernie was so cold and mean to her and
other people that she was just like
scream I'm just gonna go with with Biden
here uh but well if she's like an
example of let's say like a a left-wing
voter who's more Center then they're
going to be voting for us now because
she's Republican or at least she's she's
left the Democrat Party she's endorsing
these Maga candidates at least and so
it's like I think that the left is
hoping they can push people to the brink
basically say how much can we push you
to where you're suffering and you still
vote for us but we just can't go off the
edge well it's like they went off the
edge and so even people who run for
president as a Democrat are now
endorsing Maga candidates she also
endorsed Kerry Lake for governor yes
but she's also you know CFR so you see
the girl in The View referred to people
of the political are we going to talk
about that later tonight
but I wanna I wanna I wanna get to the
hard politics here because we have the
story from timcast.com
Biden's speech won final warning
according to white house chief of staff
in some cases we won't know the winner
of the election for a few days after the
election said Biden of midterm results
one final warning that's what he says
the president decided a few days ago
that it was important to uh issue one
final warning on this issue to make very
clear to leave no doubt that we have
people out there still peddling the big
lie people uh now raising the issue of
election Denial in this election one
final warning oh yeah old mean Joe's
coming for you if you say naughty words
about him what's the one final warning a
warning to Democrats that there's going
to be people who reject the results or
whatever
I don't understand how that makes sense
because Democrats rejected the elections
in 2016. outright rejected it and Stacy
Abrams still does
so what what's the warning what's what's
what's the pitch in this speech by uh
Biden was basically saying the only way
democracy survives is if Democrats
retain power pretty much I mean that's
essentially what he's saying here if we
lose there's going to be something fishy
going on but but if we win you better
not say something especially going on
and again this is just power trying to
hold on to power and they're losing it
they're losing it's it's just getting
gripped out of their hands right now and
one final warning I mean that sounds
like a threat that's like what parents
say to their children like one last
warning and then I'm gonna spank you
it's like okay like basically you're
saying if we don't vote for you we don't
vote for your candidates we're going to
be punished is kind of how it reads
because it's like well why can't we
evaluate the candidates in front of us
and decide this is an election but he's
basically saying before the election
even starts we're already in a place
where you know they're going to bring
hammer on us well let's be fair we are
being punished because people voted for
them so in 2020 they decided Biden was
the guy and now we all suffer because of
it so hopefully we're in the midterms
you know we're not going to change the
executive branch unless the they impeach
him and then Kamala
and then I guess you have to appoint a
republican speaker of the house could
you imagine a president McCarthy I would
not be happy but it's better than a
president Kamala like if he had to
choose I think the reason uh Biden put
in Kamala is because so many other
people would rather have him than Kamala
I mean if you're asking me right now who
do you want at the position of power
right now Kamala a sociopathic crazy
prosecutor from California or just the
old man who doesn't know where he is I
prefer the old man to be honest with you
what about you guys or the woman the the
one that has cognitive cognizance I
can't stand vacant leadership but Biden
is surrendering why would you want a
competent working government
negotiate certain things with bad people
but not crazy people if look if Joe
Biden or or you know let's we won't use
Joe Biden if an 80 year old unhinged
demented man broke into your house on
accident and he was armed and he's in
your house and he's got he's he's got a
powerful weapon
what are you gonna say to him you're
gonna be like hey there calm down buddy
what's going on he's gonna be like okay
you're like oh he's he's going nuts a
crazy person breaks in intending to do
you harm now that's bad but still
equally as dangerous however you can
still talk your way out if the person is
sane you see what I'm saying so my point
is I don't think Kamala Harris is going
to blow the world up but Joe Biden's old
and demented and may give or give orders
pertaining to the wrong country because
he's misspoken how many times he thinks
his son died in Iraq it's like it's
something he made up that's scary yeah
but still Kamala has lower approval
ratings than Biden right now oh great so
then she'll get impeached too yeah I
also feel like it's just bigger than
Biden and Kamala Harris I think we need
to like bring pain to the Democrats you
know it's like they kept impeaching
Trump they'd say oh you know this many
times impeached he's disgraced Trump
blah blah blah it's like I'm sorry but
Trump was way more popular than you guys
so we should absolutely impeach them it
doesn't even matter if you know it's
Biden and terrorists it's like they're
they're they're horrible but they should
have to live with that stain because
that's what they brought on us and they
always think oh we can do whatever we
want to you guys and you'll never do it
to us it's like wait a minute if we take
back the house the Sun and we can we we
can do it to you guys
maybe then they won't act like this
anymore
I don't know impeach them for what
exactly
Biden yeah impeach Biden over the
southern border I could name a whole
bunch of stuff yeah like but I can't say
some of it
uh the two things I can't say on this
channel one relates to a product one
relates to the treatment two relates
three uh International Chinese business
dealings it's Hunter it's Hunter
business dealings Afghanistan uh
strategic petroleum Reserve that's the
big one right there gutting our
strategic petroleum Reserve to try and
win an election while destroying
domestic energy production and
exploration sending money to Ukraine I
just just just just sorry go he's Gotta
Go I mean what he did in Afghanistan
that's just criminality right there
that's that's that's beyond words of
it's not a competence it wasn't a
mistake it's it's top level criminality
you're talking about the surrender yeah
yeah the business dealings with China
the business dealings with Ukraine
there's so much to look into but also
let's 25th amendment him
okay we're not going to say he did
anything wrong we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna go out with some Grace and
just say his brain don't work gotta go
on if it's a rule right you gotta go
yeah unfit I haven't thought much about
I thought impeachment is just kind of
like political football like now now
it's your turn next time it'll be my
turn then your turn but at some point
doing nothing is probably the wrong move
like just waiting for incompetence to
leave it doesn't want to leave they'll
stick around until you make him get out
so maybe maybe an impeachment is on the
table
I certainly think so I I think the best
government is the government that
doesn't do anything so the more
incompetent they are the more that
they're stalled the more that they don't
do anything the more happier I am
because that means the government's
going to be interfering with my life a
lot less so I'm happy that there's going
to be I I think all governments should
always have a big checks of balance on
it I think if a president is Democrat
there should be a republican uh Senate
and House to challenge him on everything
I think there should always be huge
arguments and debates I think they have
to be there for every single vote I
think they need to work at a snail's
pace and if they do that I'll be very
happy I think it would have been great
if Trump appointed Tulsi gabbard as like
National Security advisor and um
I mean yeah just right just just right
there then you're bringing in someone
who's more moderate more left lane this
is especially this is back a few years
ago when she was absolutely a Democrat I
think that would have built up a massive
Coalition and probably would have Tulsi
voters would be like we'll take it
National Security adviser to the
president Tulsi anti-intervention
way better than John Bolton I think
we'll start getting kind of stuff like
that if we have chankyuger on the show
once we start doing it personally when
we can work with the most extremely
different invited him on the show
politely never stop keep going because
he's on his way but once we start I
think as citizenry Reaching Across the
aisle interacting with people that we
might have thought our enemies
psychologically and we really can show
in good faith that we can work together
and though we disagree you'll start to
see it in politics you know the issue I
take that with that Ian is I think
you're saying that out of ignorance and
naivety no I mean I just think you'd be
the change don't expect someone else to
do it well I heard that somewhere I've
been on the ground for uh I I was
reporting on the ground for like
10 years
and I've been all over these protests
Luke and I were in occupy
having experienced this and knowing
firsthand exactly what happens when you
try and say words to these people I can
only just say to you Ian you are 100
incorrect what you are proposing is like
asking someone to flap their arms until
they fly it won't happen when when I saw
jenk Huger at Politico and I said hey
man how's it going because I know him
and I've known him for a long time
he fans me off and I was like hey look
guys you guys made a video about Dave
Rubin I don't know what your beef I have
nothing to do with it but you put my
name like front center in your video so
I was just wondering if you could they
just start screaming at me top of his
lungs in front of everybody at politicon
and I'm just like why are you yelling at
me like what's happening we've invited
him on the show numerous times all they
do is they make rage bait videos about
us taking us out of context when I
invited some of these these high profile
leftists come on the show what do they
do they lied and claimed that we were
tricking them for for to grift or
whatever and then went around hooting
and hollering that I was afraid to
debate or something it was totally fake
so at a certain point yes I get it we'll
keep trying we'll keep saying things
like we'd love to have you on the show
but bro at a certain point you have to
understand that it's just not going to
happen well there are things we have in
common with pretty much every American
well maybe not every American but you
look corporate corporations Mega
corporations the amount of power mega
Corporation has over the everyday
American's life is completely unethical
I think that [ __ ] I know Cheng euger
believes that I believe that I know that
I believe you believe that as well
you've talked we talked extensively
about BlackRock and the power that
Microsoft has and these crazy
corporations
and it's as long as we focus on our
common beliefs the little stuff like who
said what what color shirt you know who
and who you voted for AOC she's hardcore
Progressive she has now allied with like
big military she's allying with all of
these things she's supposed to be
against it's like I would love to think
people stick to their principles but for
the left it's like for them it's die
hard it's like we will stick as a team
even if it means going against
everything we believe in like I I know
that that's probably not something she
believes in but she's gonna do it
because like she's a team player but our
side's always like we have to be you
know upright on every single thing so
then we get kind of divided we have like
Libertarians like social conservatives
like these all these different groups
and then we all discuss things like
normal people but they just like think
that we shouldn't exist they think
Tucker Carlson shouldn't exist they hate
us remember when I explained bugs
bunnying someone
do you remember this oh vaguely tell me
again so uh in Looney Tunes there's Bugs
Bunny and there's uh was it was it Daffy
Daffy Duck and then Elmer Fudd has his
double barrel and he wants to figure out
which of these small Woodland creatures
he will kill
and so there's a poster on a tree and it
says rabbit season so then Bugs Bunny
tears the flyer off and it says duck
season and then Elmer turns the gun to
Daffy and then Daffy goes no it's rabbit
season then he tears it down and says
rabbit and then Elmer Fudd turns into
bugs they go back and forth arguing that
it's actually the other person's season
then finally Bugs Bunny reverses his
position and says it's rabbit season and
then Daphne goes oh no you don't it's
duck season and then bugs goes okay
Daffy it's duck season and then Elmer
fudge shoots Daffy instead and then he
goes you bugs bunnying is a term that I
I I I I use to describe when you go on
Facebook and you will see a leftist
arguing about why they hate this that or
otherwise and then what you do is you
engage them arguing their point and
slowly evolve your position to be their
original position and they will argue
against their actual post dude this
happens all the time and I do it to make
a point and then I'll say wait a a
minute you're now against social health
care this is so weird and they'll be
like well what I'm saying is and I'm
just like that's the point the point is
they hate you they hate you so much they
will vote for Joe Biden they hate you so
much they can hear John fetterman go and
they're gonna bet I'd rather have that I
mean I don't think it's no one hates
people don't hate me you could say they
hate you it's just such a generic vague
term it doesn't it might happen on his
show and said we looked this up the
story never happened and if you Google
it you find the videos are viral this
guy from Dearborn said I used to be a
Democrat I'm voting Republican and
Colbert goes on his show and said we
looked up never happened
and they goes that happened everyone's
laughing and he's mocking this family
who's begging for help this guy says I
went to the Democrats and said why are
you showing sexual images to my children
and they dismissed me and when he went
to tutor Dixon and said no more will I
vote for them Colbert went on a show
lied to the entire country because they
are evil people
he could have said this guy fund he
could have said you know that story did
happen but what was this guy really
complaining about books that were
educating kids he could have made an
argument instead he just calls the guy a
liar and then claims I looked it up it
didn't happen see this is why you have
so many people who hate and will vote
for John fetterman or Joe Biden because
they March in lockstep Behind These evil
individuals and that's the banality of
evil but then for you to be alike we
should invite them on the show we do we
do but come on dude we know for a fact
they're not coming on they go on Twitter
every single day and lie about
everything
have made video after video where you
know we did not say the things they
claim we said I really don't care I made
it and take me out of context if you
want to it's not going to stop me from
trying to work the point is what makes
you think they will sit down and have a
real conversation with you when they are
lying about you to everyone else what I
believe is there is no other that maybe
there are other ways of peacefully
figuring this out but that it's like I
don't see theological right peace I
don't see a I'm not trying to stop chant
euger from invading Poland right now
um no it's not about Neville
Chamberlain's weakness I'm talking about
diplomacy and communication amongst
civilians in the United States he wasn't
talking he was talking to German Nazi
Hitler dude uh
this is that's the goal I see the goal
is us hanging out talking about stuff
and showing the world that we can
overcome our grievances I don't know
exactly how to get there but I know that
that's a goal I think they silence us
what if they're like oh we want to say
our view they want to say their view
then they censor you like on on social
media like for the average person right
it's like they can't actually get their
views across and then not to mention
what about during like the BLM riots all
of that what if you're a store owner
you're like please don't hurt me I'm
liberal I support BLM please don't hurt
me and then they're like boom I'm gonna
ruin your store right so it's like okay
how is that going to work when people
have this complete hatred of you how
about this I think what Ian is trying to
say is be careful of mass
generalizations because there are Bad
actors that do hate you it's not always
everyone I think that's what you're
trying for sure but also I just wanted
to make another argument just to counter
your point a little bit here because
when you say you know they're all in
line here we should do the same I I
don't think we should because I think
not being a line I think questioning and
arguing is a strength and I think their
cultist beliefs and ideas staying in
line is a weakness and overall a bad
thing let me pull up this I think we
should be like AOC I don't think we
should give up like our principles in
order to sell out to some you know
company I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that I do think the left goes to
the extreme to do that and our side
generally doesn't do that let me pull up
this story from the Washington examiner
The View host Compares Republican women
to roaches voting for raid
quote what's also surprising to me is
the abortion issue I read a poll just
yesterday that white Republicans
Suburban women are now going to vote
Republican she told her co-hosts it's
almost like roaches voting for raid she
was interrupted by Alyssa Farah Griffin
who accused hosted of insulting voters
the when you have people
who refuse to understand your position
and then listen to Stephen Colbert to
try and understand what your position is
and then he lies to them and says your
position is fake and doesn't exist
how are you supposed to have a
reasonable conversation to move this
country forward when these ideological
zealots outright refuse to even have a
conversation uh start your own show that
was my experience if you don't like what
they're saying about you you got to
start speaking for yourself publicly
right and we've done that and now we
can't expect the woman who is calling
women roaches to want to sit down here
and have a conversation about why she's
wrong I would talk to her but that
convert that sure is crazy can we play
that that short clip of her I mean it's
basically every time you start the
message out you had something you wanted
to say well yeah um I would say if
you're answering that part which party's
getting the message out I would actually
say the Republicans are and I tend to
vote independently watch foreign
[Applause]
women are now going to vote Republican
why it's almost like roaches voting for
raid right now
she is so arrogant and hateful her
immediate assumption is do these women
want to live in Gilead they're voting
against their own interests we have a
pro-life woman sitting here is voting
pro-life against your in interests
absolutely not I don't know what in her
mind makes her think that abortion is
somehow good for women I mean even if
you are a woman who's been through that
I would say almost every woman who's
been in that situation is horrible it's
not something you want it's not like you
know getting an ice cream cone or or
doing something fun it's it's a very sad
thing and it's it's horrible that leads
to psychological and physical damage yes
many people don't want to talk about
right have regrets over doing that and
so on but aside from that this isn't
something that is something that they
look towards so I think the fact that
the left wants this to be their main
issue for the midterms they basically
want it to be all about January 6th
their democracy being lost in abortion
those are like they're two big things
they want people to vote on and it's
like maybe women actually want intact
families maybe they actually want to be
safe in their neighborhoods they want
men to be men they want all these other
things they don't actually want abortion
why don't we avoid that situation I
think most women would disagree with her
and would not like being called roaches
obviously if she she wants women to vote
leftists in the midterms and they're
watching this this is not a way to
attract them but I can I can certainly
imagine there are many women who want to
be able to get abortions whenever they
want genuinely deep within their souls
they just would love to get an abortion
I mean Lena Dunham said she wished she
had one despite not actually having a
kid she was like no she just wish she
got pregnant that was kind of crazy but
to say that pro-life women who don't
like abortion who want to have babies
and families are voting against their
interests for knowing exactly what they
want is the the epitome of arrogance and
hatred how about she actually let pharah
speak is that her name Alyssa actually
Alyssa speak and say I genuinely don't
understand why a what Republican woman
would vote against her interests can you
explain it to me and then she'd say well
it's not against her interest is it they
believe that these are babies and they
don't want their lives ended so they
wouldn't get an abortion and they don't
think it should be supported hey it's
that simple and perhaps these women
voting think that it's in the best
interest of the child to not kill them I
mean we have to consider all the people
in play what about fathers they often
say how do I have access to my child
even in child custody things they don't
have any say when it comes to abortion
they have no say so I think that there's
so much more to this than just you know
is this in her in her best interest and
I would say it's not in her best
interest it's not in the child's best
interest it's not in anyone's best in
interest in that entire family unit so
what ends up happening with a lot of
policies there's a lot of I think really
important and great things that came out
of the feminist movement I think that's
uh most everybody would agree like women
can vote I know there's a lot of people
who say repeal the 19th but you know
most people are like no that's we're
cool with it although you know there are
a lot of social issues that are
happening now that people argue about I
think what you end up seeing with a lot
of feminist stuff however is detrimental
to women so when you look at hookup
culture who does that benefit men not
women
just just plain as day and and mostly
like wealthier taller you know more
attractive dudes they can fool around do
whatever they want with no
responsibilities used to be that if a
guy want to hook up with a chick and he
did you're getting married because she's
getting pregnant now who cares get an
abortion what was it was it Portnoy he
was talking Dave Portnoy was talking
about this he was debating I think
Andrew Tate on this issue and he was
basically saying like if he gets a girl
pregnant he wants her to get rid of it
you know yeah that's way better for a
guy who doesn't want to be responsible
to for anything and it puts the burden
on women who are now pregnant so the
response so then what ends up happening
is you build a culture where women say
okay then I should be able to just get
rid of it sure I get it but the burden
is still on the woman no matter what it
still benefits the man more if the man
wants to be irresponsible and I think
it's so sad that the left tries to act
like a man giving you 500 to go to an
abortion clinic is empowering that's
like similar to prostitution basically
saying I'm gonna give you money so like
go do this it's like working for a mega
multinational corporation and giving all
of your energy and life towards them is
empowering but supporting your family
isn't
why that the left has sold women
basically that you'll be happy if you
spend all your time in a cubicle you
know there was an article that came out
saying the most unhappy women are women
who are single in their 40s who don't
have any children and work all the time
and it's like big shock yeah because I
mean you're told in your 20s work all
the time work all the time and I totally
get that but at a certain point there
has to be more to life than that and
eventually women say oh I want kids I
want a family then they're like oh my
gosh I'm so old what do I do now and
that's why all of these alternate
fertility things are exploding and it's
very unnatural but needless to say it's
like I think things need to go back to a
more a more natural sense of of the two
genders now that's obviously going to be
very upsetting to the left but
conservative women are the happiest
women who who get married have children
have a stable relationship you know it
might be tough but working things
through I think they're much happier
well that's a fact there's there's
numerous studies that show conservative
women married women tend to have higher
levels of happiness and liberal women
tend to have the highest levels of
mental illness so for whatever reason I
don't know but there's a LexisNexis data
there's the data scientists who have
pointed this all out I don't see I I
think a lot of the left stuff is going
too far and there's a lot of good things
in it that we're all like okay you know
we believe in like classical liberal
values Free Speech you know um innocent
until proven guilty and everyone should
have the right to vote our society
changes as the population grows larger
but they get to the point where it's
like the state can take your children uh
marriage is basically voided out by no
fault divorce there's no point having a
marriage like so here's another thing
they lied lied about uh they lied about
when it came to us is we had a
conversation about no fault divorce
we were very critical of it they falsely
quoted Ian as Sheamus I'll never forgive
you for that Sheamus who was it was it
Jezebel yeah yeah and um but the issue
with no fault divorce is that when you
when you say that you can get divorced
for no reason
then you're basically saying marriage no
longer exists because marriage was the
contract by which you could not break
till death do us part then they're like
no you can just right you're done you
know sign up his paper and then split
your money up and you're good okay well
what's the point of getting married so
that you can pledge your stuff for a few
years somebody else why do that yeah
it's meaningless yeah a lot of men I
think ask that because they're like oh
I'm basically just agreeing to give
someone money who will take it if they
divorce me and it's like whoa what about
all of the other good things about
marriage which I think it's mostly for
the children it's to create an
environment where they have two parents
in the home of course that's not always
the case great people that's you know
they didn't have that situation but I do
think in general that's what you want to
strive towards and I think the left
wants to destroy that they want to take
kids from their parents send them into
Wilkes schools teach them things saying
hey here's why you should hate your
parents here's why you know your parents
are crazy and all this stuff so no
matter what they want to kind of change
the whole dynamic of society which I do
think goes back to the home
yep yeah without uh family kids are more
likely to drop out of school they're
more likely which well at this point
maybe it's not a bad thing yeah with two
parents working who's going to raise the
children the state you also lower uh
working wages you also increase the tax
base and this is why there's a theory
out there that a lot of this you know
was started because of Edward Bernays
and robber barons and the Rothschilds
that were pushing a lot of these ideas
forward in order to make sure that at
the end of the day they had a system
that benefited them and they were able
to control Society even more yeah at
this point it's If the parents aren't
there is it's not even the state really
if it's functionalism it's the
corporation it's not a television it's
Disney it's it's Microsoft if they're on
the computer it's it's Facebook and
Twitter and who controls Facebook and
Twitter the federal government I would
like the DHS and they're dictating what
a whole scene in the algorithm I hope
and they're dictating who has a voice
and doesn't have a voice the
multinational corporations are in bed
with the government and with the big
Banks here so at the end of the day it's
still the same interests control
trolling and shaping the minds of the
children as two parents have to work and
leave their children with you know cell
phones in their hands or some Nanny that
doesn't care about them or some State
institution that indoctrinates them to
be essentially a good worker I really
support liberalism in in the sense of
like classical like we're becoming more
uh more free in our society we have more
liberal arts we're able to sing in
public we're able to insult our
government we're able to vote for who we
want and charge uh but it's getting to
the point now where it's becoming
transhumanist and these this this
excessively liberal agenda being like
you can be whatever you want you can do
whatever you want people are cutting
themselves they're they're cutting parts
of themselves off to become what they
want to become and it's like this is
like this is a toxic liberalism there's
a there's an individual who identifies
as a paraplegic woman he's biologically
male and he identifies this is I think
this is in Norway Norway yes he
identifies as a paraplegic woman so even
though his legs work he gets in a
wheelchair and and then says he's a
disabled one that's his identity you
have to respect it at a certain point we
have to start asking questions of where
what are the limits of identity if
someone says they're disabled but
they're not can they claim disabled
benefits like that's that's that's where
we're going yeah but let's we'll keep it
to the politics Ian because I'm really
glad you you brought up this stuff
because we've got more of the craziness
to talk about
Joe Biden gives a speech where he says
that the dangerous Maga Republicans they
must be stopped they're a threat to this
country from The Daily Mail Republican
candidates kids are almost killed after
gunman opens fire at his North Carolina
home with bullet Landing a few feet from
where they slept after Democrat rival
filmed campaign ad outside his property
remember Lee zeldin not only uh he was
he was attacked on stage didn't didn't
someone go to his house there was like a
shootout
was that zeldon's house I think there
was a stray bullet that hit his house
people outside the house were shooting
in the bullet when his house yep so this
is uh the reality a bullet landed in Pat
harrigan's Hickory North Carolina home I
believe it was his parents home but his
kids were there his children and parents
were inside at the time but no one was
injured the FBI are now investigating
the ballistics according to a local
Report Green Beret Harrigan wears a
bulletproof vest and has been targeted
by threats his Democrat opponent Jeff
Jackson has pulled in pulled an ad shot
outside his home
like come on dude but Tim Biden says
that Mega Republicans are the biggest
threat to our safety
does anyone has anyone worried that a
group like any sane person worried a
group of Maga Republicans are going to
go out and like Rampage through a city
with with masks and fire bombs and
molotovs where you know fighting with
cops I'm not I'm worried about nobody
false flags and international
corporations doing stuff no the reality
is you'll be a trump supporter driving
your truck through a city waving your
little Trump flag and then you'll Park
and get out and some far left psychopath
will put two bullets in your chest
or you'll be running for office and
somebody will fire a gun into your
parents home nearly hitting your
children
but Joe Biden wants to come out so I was
watching uh there's this clip from MSNBC
of Bill Maher funny Bill Maher said two
years ago Civil War can't happen now
he's saying it is happening
um
he's he's he said that he's like it's
it's the it's the right the violent
Reddit from the right that's making this
happen I mean there was a drag drag
queen Story Hour and they attacked it I
guess and I'm just like amazing Bill
amazing you have no idea what you're
talking about but to come out and climb
at the people who almost never protest
are the bigger threat than people who
caused over two billion dollars in
damage during the 529 Insurrection
forced the president into a bunker tore
it on the barricades of the White House
set fire to a guard post and set fire to
St John's Church
they did nothing wrong apparently is
that what you're saying and like what
about the person who tried to kill
Kavanaugh one of our Supreme Court
justices they just act like these things
don't ever happen like if we went
through a whole list of all of the
people who've been attacked like you
know that um that young person who was
seeing that hospital bed for wearing a
Maga hat it's like they don't even care
about this stuff they just want to focus
on their message which is that we're a
real danger or how about the kid in uh
where was it was it North Dakota or
where he got run over by the crazy guy
oh yeah he said that he was part of a
Maga a republican extremist group so he
ran him down
crushed him
and then what happened with the charges
related to that was he the the person
who did it he got released on bail
that's right yeah the Kyle Rittenhouse
not him he gets locked up for almost
three months in solitary by himself
and in horrible conditions we think he
later came out and spoke about think
about the Covington Catholic situation
a child on a school field trip was
standing minding his own business when
an adult man walked right up to his face
and started banging a drum and the kid
didn't move
and the media took an out of context
clip of the incident blamed the kid for
it and these blue checks across Twitter
started sending death threats to him
okay you get it are we supposed to be
like I know you just threatened to throw
children to a wood chipper base even
though they were the victims but why
don't we come together and have you sit
down and have a peaceful conversation
I'll tell you what's funny is we do
still invite them but you need to
understand what these people represent
I'm all about subverting the cultural
opponent but if it was 1936 Nazi Germany
and I started screaming about how evil
the Nazis were I'd be the first one up
against the wall so I'm not playing that
game right now okay well I'd rather be
the guy who didn't salute in that crowd
of people who were saluted I'd rather be
Einstein fled the freakishness and built
something awesome
bailout I guess I don't blame people for
fleeing these cities because of that
stuff to be honest
built a nuclear weapon that he felt
really bad about that is now bringing us
on the brink of the total Destruction of
free Humanity well it was coming anyway
he was just part of it correct this is
actually really funny real quick just
about World War II is there were a lot
of scientists working on fission or
Fusion it was a fission fission and they
were Jewish so they fled and if Hitler
wasn't doing what he was doing they
would have had the nukes
crazy they were working on some crazy
technology but then the scientists fled
and then we got them and then we used
them flying saucers like it it goes deep
it's crazy so anyway I say something oh
no I was gonna say something about
earlier about the the kids wearing Maga
hats being attacked I just think like
young people that's happening not just
like college campus level not just
adults but like little children which is
why I think so many parents are
homeschooling now like homeschooling's
exploded since covid because they see
what they're being taught and also it's
like you can't even be yourself around
your friends you're just going to be
bullied by them like so many young
conservatives I mean just feel like I
can't even tell anyone I'm conservative
they need to though that's it I'm sorry
you know it's like do you believe in it
or not are you gonna keep hiding because
the reality is
with with 10 kids
there may be one who's like I can't tell
anybody that I actually feel this way
about these politics because they'll
bully me and then it turns out they all
feel the same way and they're all scared
of each other and this fake lie that
that sits on the surface I find that
there's a tendency to want to people
want to I build an identity for
themselves young people particularly and
sometimes they'll say like IMA fill in
the blank I am a liberal I am a
conservative I am a republican I am a
Christian and they'll like Define a box
with which in they lie and they cannot
then as a result of that can't if they
step out of it then they'll start to
feel guilt so they'll and then other
people will be like well I have an idea
of what I think that box is so you're
that I'm gonna treat you like that and
it's like you can be conservative and
liberal and you can be a liberal
conservative like you don't have to to
stop you don't have to like hide behind
a wall of words or anything it wasn't
always like this I I still remember a
few years ago it was protesters fighting
police officers police officer fighting
protesters but now it's protesters
fighting protesters and and people
getting at each other and I don't think
it was correct me if I'm wrong but for
my my experiences I I don't ever
remember it being this tumultuous
between political parties between the
left wing and the right wing I I don't
remember a time in the 90s where people
would see each other as political
opposites and then really want to harm
each other I think we have escalated to
this state which is worrisome and is
only escalating because of just the
nonsense being pushed on by the
corporate media and big Tech social
media which is being controlled by of
course the intelligence agencies that
are calling the shots on what we see so
you know I don't know was there a time
where there was this much I mean
obviously we had a civil war in this
country but that was a very long time
ago but but in recent history what got
us here how how are we here at this
point where you can't even you know
openly talk about politics I was like
really outspoken about my dislike for
George Bush Jr's war in Iraq and
Afghanistan and I would there's talk
directly to George I'm still talking to
you man on the internet like listen up
dude but I never had animosity towards
Republicans I didn't care who he was
voted for like if I just wanted to help
you Enlighten you like look at what
there were no weapons of mass
destruction that was a lie they lied to
get us into Iraq look and then people
are like oh okay okay and if you're
reasonable and you're not angry I'm not
angry people I'm actually enjoying like
enlightening people they tend to go for
it I think it was like you're saying
that it was big Tech because it was like
in 20 2012 Facebook when they started
sending like the violence to the top of
the algorithmic feed a shooting and then
you'd see and then that would get 60 000
re tweets or like likes or whatever and
uh because it was popular they pushed it
and then it became more popular and it's
easy to hate uh it's a real challenging
to love like it takes a lot of humility
we want to try and talk to regular
people who aren't super political
we want people to hear a message that
pulls them from the cult but I don't
think that means we go to cult leaders
and beg them to have a conversation with
us because they would only exploit it to
expand their cult yeah I tend to have
the conversation with them and if
they're and just just believe that
they're listening whether they're there
or not whether they respond or not I
said my piece you heard it and then let
I'm not I expect nothing I don't expect
you know response or anything like that
but at least you say your piece you
directly confront who you want to
confront and explain yourself
and I feel like the left became really
radical under Obama because when it was
um you know Clinton Bush it was kind of
like they were in the same Club they
were too you know very elitist people
they both kind of had similar views on
things honestly I feel like America was
much more of a center place which in a
way it's like okay good less arguments
and stuff like now but also bad because
we're not actually changing things that
much it's like everybody in this one
class is in the you know political Elite
but then when Obama came I think he was
the first one it was like a true
ideologue who was really had this like
far left-wing agenda and the Republicans
at the time were like no no Obama and
then people thought oh there's gonna be
hope there's gonna be a change we're
going to be so United racism is going to
be gone because there's going to be this
black president and then of course
things only got worse they only made the
tensions even worse and they didn't
actually solve anything so then I think
when Trump came along we were like oh my
gosh like we have to counter the things
happening there and I do think normal
people like you were saying want to
discuss things with other people like
all the time I'll talk to someone you
know I grew up in California who's
liberal we'll talk about stuff but I
think like the famous people like you
were saying who are these radical
leftists it's like yeah they don't
they're they're not going to have their
minds changed as much by talking they're
making money changing their minds yeah
when you're making money for espousing
your beliefs it's kind of reinforces the
beliefs whether they're right or wrong
and people will believe wrong idea
beliefs too if they like you if you're
charismatic we have a show where we
invite you know we try to have these
people on we've had a few progressives
who I think we're cool and I'm glad they
came on uh Jen Pearlman she's great uh
Progressive was running in Florida and
we disagreed a lot of things but it's
really cool it's awesome too yeah we do
we she was super cool good conversation
where we actually got to find out where
they're coming from and what led them to
the decisions and thoughts and ideas
that they have and I think we need more
of that but here's the thing someone
like Jen
become someone like Tulsi where it's
like you have these ideas and beliefs
you end up trying you try to talk with
people and say we need to solve these
problems you come on a show like Tim
cast IRL and we go well we disagree with
those ideas and they're like but I'm
glad we have the conversation and then
the left calls that person far right and
says they're a conservative now and so
the media writes that I'm a conservative
and conservatives absolutely are like
there's no way Tim's a conservative like
just absolutely not but the media will
just say it because they they want to
thank the the well they want to Poison
the Well so you know my goal what I want
to see happen is a decentralized network
individuals all discussing these ideas
the best rise at the top we solve our
problems because everyone's working
towards solving them the problem with
many of these establishment Elites
uniparty Elites left-wing cultists is
that they just think they're smarter and
better than you Bloomberg says tax the
poor because we're smarter and we know
better that's what the mentality that
guides them which means they will lie
for the sake of gaining power and then
the worst part is they will lie claiming
it's you who's lying it's like that
riddle where you come to a fork in the
road and there's two two guys standing
outside one always lies one that always
tells the truth but they both accuse
each other of being the one who's trying
to you know do you wrong because once
telling you the truth and one's lying
and that's like the idea of the better
men that are like we need a senate
because if the masses can decide with
mob mentality they'll wreck the country
so we need a group of more intelligent
more educated people that are stop Gap
you're overthinking but it's like it's
to the extreme now I'm a better man I
know better than you yeah maybe there
are people that are just destroyed
psychologically on sugar and they
they're incapable of leading I don't
know you're partly right about the
better men thing with the Senate but I
think that was a quote from one person
the idea of the of the federal Senate
being appointed by state legislature by
the state representatives or the state
senate I think it was between the two of
them is that we vote in our state we the
people we have our state then the states
send their representatives to the
federal government the sen the Senate
represents the states so it is up to the
state to decide who represents them so
the state would vote for the person get
it yeah and then the 17th Amendment
changed that and I think that was a huge
mistake we were better off when people
had to know who their local politicians
were
you see these ads about you know
Congress and they're like if you vote
for me I'll clean up the city and I'm
like no you won't you're going to DC and
you go to DC and you're going to vote on
foreign policy taxes and guns and stuff
which is good we need you to do it but
if you want to see your streets cleaned
up you got to vote for your local your
local politicians people don't know that
and this this nationalization of
politics has actually eroded the country
and turned it into some
I don't know what you'd call it the
problem whatever it is today with the
establishment Elites it's because of of
what how we've changed things yeah yeah
you don't want your Senators beholden to
your common your commenters you want
your Senators behold in all new state
legislature uh if anybody I think and
that's I mean I'm saying it
tongue-in-cheek but it's kind of true
like you don't want the mob to tell the
senate what to do the Senate's there to
protect us from the mob we have congress
the people have Congress and they go and
represent your District to the federal
government and then the Senators
represent the states that's why each
state has two no matter what the
population size is even Delaware which
is microscopic and Rhode Island which is
also microscopic and I love when they
come out and they're like when when
Montana gets two senators and I'm like
yeah yeah yeah Delaware gets two
senators too come on I know they have
cities and they have like a million or
whatever people but don't don't come at
me and complain with the size of I'd
argue that there's Wyoming and Montana
should have more votes because of how
much land mass they control and the
resources that are available there one
tiny small City Providence and all of a
sudden they get two senators it's kind
of like the as social media admins are
acting like an unelected Senate these
corporate like how are they able to veto
what we say in public
they have more power than Senators I
think and probably most governments like
Google YouTube like they're a monopoly
they literally control probably the the
speech and what people see of like
millions of people
I mean not to mention you know Facebook
Twitter all these other things and I
mean hopefully things get better but I
do think that a lot of this is is going
to be like mind control as long as
people are so focused on devices which
is why I think people should absolutely
not give their kids like an iPad just to
look at all day how many hours oh are
you last thing you say no no I was just
gonna say I think that it at first we
thought oh wow technology amazing all of
these things are happening this is great
which is great I get to talk to my
family in India like wow so many changes
from just one generation but I do think
there are so many harmful effects and
you can't just have this like unlimited
addiction to technology I wanna I wanna
I wanna give people some good news some
good news okay from the New York Post
Don lemon's new show CNN this morning
bombs in debut yo he only he was only
able to get 71 000 key demo viewers you
know I'm pretty sure that I mean we get
we get 60 percent of that number just in
concurrent viewership up on this in fact
we do right now have 43 000 people
watching live and that is key demo
viewership for the most part that means
in like 10 minutes we will have more
viewers than Don Lemon got on his
Morning Show but wait there's more CNBC
cancels Shep Smith's evening news
program the dude could have just stayed
where he was and reported the news but
he had Trump derangement syndrome and
now he has no job and then you get this
Jake tapper's rating deficient CNN
Primetime show to end after the midterms
so I'm feeling good how you guys feeling
it's fun I feel like the old guards on
its way out and the new guard is
established we I think we got to open up
that uh expensive bottle of booze here
in order to celebrate this this you know
Changing of the Guard as some people
would call it but you know who would
have thought you know propaganda doesn't
pay huh statism and and just lying to to
people on the heads of the very powerful
didn't work lying didn't work yeah what
a surprise sad
I think they just have no audience it's
like Trump was right he basically said
you know CNN is fake news and it's true
like they literally don't have a
constituency at least MSNBC I think
talks to like leftists that's their
audience Fox News talks to like
right-wing people and CNN they're just
like yeah you know we just want to keep
on saying how we hate Trump make all of
our news about Trump and who's our
audience gonna be then the new guy who
takes over says you know we'll make
things independent we're not really
going to be biased anymore well that
didn't happen so I mean these people are
entertaining if you're not doing
politics could be entertaining but
they're not funny maybe you know I'll
see what uh Chris Licht can pull off
with CNN he's getting rid of these
people Jake Tapper is gone take a look
take a look at this picture CNN this
morning there's Don Lemon all very happy
it's like hey you're doing a Morning
Show so don't wear don't wear a tie
anymore like don't wear a butt nut so
it's a jacket with a t-shirt under it
and like that's that's the vibe it's
it's look relatable look happy it's so
cringy pastel pink got this really nice
turquoise there's no amount of money CNN
could offer
any serious person to go and try and do
something with them I'm sorry I would go
it could totally change everything at
CNN if they asked me to do a hit Prime
Time show a hit Prime Time show I would
take I wouldn't take myself seriously
that's the problem with these peoples
they're afraid of looking like fools and
it's okay to look like a fool the
audience agrees I would I would go
outside and get a steaming pile of trash
and then just do a live stream of that
and that would probably get more views
than what they're getting right now
we'll do the trash that they're getting
they have no but frail though it would
if CNN right now announced they were
replacing Tapper with a steaming pile of
trash it would get like 5 million views
on its debut night no joke the next day
it would get about a million and then it
would consistently hit about a million
from people who are like how long is
this going to go on for them just
showing steaming trash well you get
different angles of cameras with they
can zoom way in so you can see the
bacteria growing in real time and then
it's really you know entertaining dude I
would I would turn that on I would watch
it if in fact if CNN announced that I'd
be concerned they would pull our viewers
away I'd be like oh man you know are
going to want to watch that if they like
dumped Gatorade on Don lemon's head when
he wasn't expecting it it would get 100
million views yeah you slimed on Lemon
you let it go ahead of time we're gonna
slime you at some point today oh dude I
I I I okay so I'm assuming the reason
that fire down lemon is because he's
under contract if I was if I was Chris
licked and I was taking over CNN and I I
couldn't fire him I'd be like your show
it's gonna be great You're Gonna Go on
stage and the audience are all going to
have
buzzers
and when at least 10 people in the
audience press the button you get slimed
so there's 30 people in the audience
that means you better say the right
thing otherwise the audience is going to
send you to slime town maybe they gotta
let Don slime himself wait no one likes
to be slimed against their will so don
you just take it upon yourself at some
point tonight I'm slamming myself he's
gonna be called slime lemon slime I got
an idea I got an idea so you know how we
do a chicken City that if people give a
hundred thousand super chats it
accumulates and then the chicken party
happens you could do something like that
where Don lemon's sitting at a desk with
a soccer horn right next to his head and
he's just sweating as he reads the news
and people are sending in money to the
show and every hundred dollars it goes
just right in his face and I gotta
they'd make bangs yeah I don't want to
objectify Donnie though I feel like it
would just be like a way to roast them
and they people would love to see them
like really well dressed like you know
like man cured in the morning just
totally slimed I think people would
really enjoy that right I would listen
listen if CNN is failing and every
everyone hates these people that's where
the money's at baby yeah you got to be
like hey look the audience hates you
guys and you're under contract let's
make money off it yeah what can we do
how about there's a a big cartoon hand
with a glove and it loads pies and every
you know 500 it launches a pie at the at
the host what's the what's the game
where you get dunked in the water
they're sitting they're sitting in this
like a little adult yeah they're they're
sitting on the dunk tank reporting the
news and every time they get something
wrong they get dunked into the water
what about factually incorrect I like I
like pies I like
um sliming them big fan of slime I feel
like the only person who'd played these
fun games is Trump he's the only one who
doesn't take himself too seriously and
would be willing to actually throw
himself out there like do you remember
when he was riding in that car at that
big race car thing and everyone was like
screaming they were just cheering for
him I don't know like he knows how to
get the crowd going I feel like he'd be
able to like make really good TV make
good ratings these people they're just
like sticks like they just don't want to
step even a second outside of their
comfort zone and I also think like
people who are content creators make
YouTube videos they would see like oh
this is a video Someone really liked let
me do that again let me do the same
thing or let me try something new but
these people are corporate media so
they're not interested in trying new
things they just want people to accept
what they are putting out at one point
he said maybe a black could it have been
a black hole that swallowed the plane
and I
he'd been goofing around maybe he was
just letting his psycho his psychosis
run but I mean it didn't do well it
didn't play well for the for the network
him saying that which is too bad because
we need that goofiness I think I
remember when Trump was at a rally and
he was like these lights they make me
look orange they make me orange and
everyone's laughing and he's like he's
self-aware yeah
the swimmer the man like passing the
woman and he's like oh she has like a
wind burn because he just like swims
past her so quick it's like he just
comes up with like the best comments
it's not fun
this Shep Smith you know on CNBC Don
Lemon it's not fun and this and you can
see it in the in the videos they were
trying to make it fun and it's not look
at this the three of them sitting there
looking at Hillary Clinton on the big
screen is just nightmarishly cringe it's
just like dude let go at least have a
hologram of Hillary there in the room
like Fox something high-tech I think Fox
did that right remember when Fox did the
chef smith thing were they the giant
tablets
that was so cringe as well oh yeah yeah
they had giant tablets and they were all
excited like the future of The Newsroom
is gigantic screens that you can like
use your hands and I'm like I'm pretty
sure that's not the future of The
Newsroom dude but you know whatever man
what do you think's gonna CNN's gonna
turn into
is it like QVC they're gonna be selling
and chucking and jiving like the latest
beauty products and and jewelry be like
I could see Don Lemon doing that that
could be a very I mean they got to make
money somehow what does it CNN does that
mean what does it mean Cable News
Network news Well Cable's done so they
don't read that name anymore well I mean
there's still a lot of money in cable uh
because people still do use it and now
what we're seeing with these uh
streaming services they're creating
bundles that are basically the same
thing as cable was but now it's just
online so I think the cable industry is
not going to go any I think what they're
going to do is they're going to convert
into online streaming providers but CNN
plus such a failure
for CNN plus had to say
um I did how much did they spend but you
know I think like they're gonna hold on
till the end because they're like oh
we're still kind of riding on our
coattails from when like people liked
this kind of thing but I think if they
try to transition to CNN plus type
content it's like people already made it
known that they don't want that content
you would have to get someone to Rebrand
the network work like someone totally
like someone like Tim or something like
someone completely
knew that's like independent new fun
willing to say whatever I mean and I
mean whatever but I guess the problem is
that they're funded by
military industrial you know I I gotta I
gotta imagine that that's a fair point
see the thing is I don't trust CNN I
imagine that they'll they'll say
something like look we're trying to do
right and we want to you know be more
relatable why don't you come and fix it
if you take them up on that offer then a
day later they're like here's why war is
good read it and you're gonna be like
but I don't want to read it and they're
going to be like read it you know
otherwise they're gonna lock you in a
room and put you in golden handcuffs and
or threaten like if you say that it
violates your contract some abstract
thing they'll have like a 70 page
contract that they want you to sign
before you start oh I've seen them
they're ridiculous huge contracts
they're like not 70 but it's like you
know maybe I mean close to it actually
with like vague terminology like
anything that we make morality Clauses
where it's like if you say if you offend
someone's delicate sensibilities they
can terminate your contract and it's
just ridiculous it's like that they
bought who discovery bought CNN is that
right the IPA I think the discovery owns
yeah it's like buying VHS in like 1997.
like now I own the VCR VHS or betamax
like what are you gonna do with VHS now
it's a dead brand it doesn't the age of
the video cassette tape is is now done
the age of like stodgy news reporters
pretending to tell you the truth they
tried with Casey neistat that was CNN
right CNN hired Casey and I said and
then he made beam or whatever or he
turned beam into CNN or something and it
didn't work I guess I don't know they
did it and they were getting views or
whatever but then they just stopped
maybe they were doing a lot of paid
promotion that wasn't paying off I feel
like they're never going to be fun or
entertaining so that's off the table but
I think if they did real journalism then
people would really appreciate it
obviously I realize that's completely
far-fetched not gonna happen but they're
supposed to like you know like question
presidential candidates and debates and
they're supposed to do serious things
it's like they're not like the Real
Housewives of New York or something like
they're supposed to do some serious work
although that would be pretty funny but
I I just think journalism is lost and
they're choosing not to be journalists
agreed let's have some fun let's talk
about Kanye West we have this uh tweet
Kanye says what what should be obvious
by now is that I was raised to stand for
my truth regardless of the consequences
so I will say this again I was mentally
misdiagnosed and nearly drugged out of
my mind to make me a manageable
well-behaved celebrity here's a text he
posted from someone named Harley that
says I'm going to help you one of a
couple ways first you and I sit down and
have a have an loving and open
conversation but you don't use cuss
words and everything that is discussed
is based in fact and not some crazy
stuff that dumb friend of yours told you
or you saw in a tweet second option I
have you institutionalized again where
they medicate the crap out of you and
you go back to Zombieland forever play
date with the kids just won't be the
same wow that's evil I just it's that's
insane man that's scary stuff it's also
blackmail I think I don't know who this
person is what kind of power they have
well I don't even know if the Texas
doctor to be honest but I don't think
Kanye would lie but I don't know I was
watching Nathan for you because he's got
a he's got he's got a new show coming
out so like HBO put him on the front
page and I saw him I'm like yeah I've
never watched it so I did
for those that are familiar with the
show he says that he like graduated from
business school and he wants to help
businesses get new customers it's not
true it's just a funny reality show it's
comedy he goes to a TV shop
that's losing business because of Best
Buy and so he says here's what we're
going to do we are going to exploit Best
Buy's price match policy we're going to
sell your TVs for a dollar then go to
Best Buy and say see look they're for a
dollar so we can buy all your TVs
the problem is how do you stop people
from actually buying the TVs for a
dollar because you'd lose them all so he
requires them to wear a tuxedo dress
code to come into the store this is what
Nathan Nathan Fielder does then he says
if they actually show up in tuxedo they
have to crawl through a tiny door two
feet tall on the ground if they make it
through there the TVs are in a room with
an alligator
and it's just it's absolutely insane
it's a hilarious show
now he says I'm worried that the guy is
going to get sued by Best Buy I know how
to prevent him from from that happening
a legal Insanity diagnosis
he goes to a psychiatrist and he says my
friend is insane he thinks he's a
manager and electronics store and is not
and I want you to talk to him
so she's talking to him and says how are
you and he says you know it's great I
work in an electronic store I've been
doing it she goes oh and you like it
goes yes and she goes oh okay and then
Nathan says ask him about the alligator
and then she goes oh I didn't know and
then he starts explaining this story
about people in tuxedos crawling through
two foot doors and then getting scared
of an alligator and then she says he's
psychotic he's completely detached from
reality and that was a that was scary I
mean the show's really really funny but
that story right there I think is really
important because what's what you what
you have with Kanye is that he can say
something he says things that are
outrageous don't get me wrong but you
could say something that people don't
believe and then they could
institutionalize you and Drug you and
lock you up and have everyone believe
that you're nuts and then the crazy
thing is he's saying he was nearly
drugged out of his mind some of the
crazy things he may have been saying was
because they were pumping him full of
crazy drugs yeah
I know that it came out in the Lex
Freeman podcast with yay that he was
exhausted it was like a he had a bout of
exhaustion that landed him in the
hospital and they treated it like a
mental diagnosis
and that's the whole thing remember from
like four years ago and it's like oh
Kanye was in the hospital and that's
when they were drugging him I guess a
lot of these big Pharma pills have a lot
of unintended consequences especially
when it comes to messing with your brain
chemistry which is not an exact science
each person has a different brain
chemistry each person's brain works
different than the other person so just
throwing pills at it I mean this would
explain some of the kind of more manic
behavior by Kanye especially if if he
has just been given pills or even worse
forced to take pills and this could also
explain why a lot of people are having
psychotic breakdowns especially in
Hollywood uh you know and and this could
be a big conspiracy here that that he's
unraveling that I think is worth paying
attention to because when when we look
at doctors when we look at big Pharma
they have a lot of power when it comes
to the individual and they could they
could force you to take drugs that could
mess you up for the rest of your life
and just like this this guy says he'll
make sure that play dates with the kids
just won't be the same I mean that's
real life consequences for the rest of
his life and and you're saying that he's
going to be medicated forever so this is
this is a big deal this is this is
something worth talking about I also
feel like there was so much sympathy for
Britney Spears with free Brittany which
I agree with but I just don't think
Kanye's gonna get the same thing because
he's been remotely Maga I mean I don't
even think he's you know it's
conservative in every way like you were
saying people kind of can be free
thinkers I think he is a free thinker he
has certain views on certain things and
I don't think that people are going to
Rally behind him if he's being forced to
take drugs because of his political
views when I think a lot of people
rallied behind free Brittany
yeah yeah he tweeted that he's he's what
is all the stuff he's posting
oh is he going after people now oh man
he's a sweet story by name yeah I'm
looking at his Twitter right now I'm
trying to read it it's a lot of
information well that's what Lex Freeman
incursion but he's like rather than just
scream about an ethnic group of people
name people name them yeah go for it I
don't think they canceled him because of
that I think it was because of political
stuff I think that was just an excuse
they were like oh great now here's a
great example of why we can cancel him
well you know I don't think that's what
it was I mean Harry you know Prince
Harry Harry and Megan like he wore a
Nazi outfit it's like we can go through
people and come up with reasons to
cancel them but it's like come on I mean
they obviously just don't like his
political views yeah and then there's uh
Northam we're not sure if he was the guy
in blackface or the guy in the clown
outfit but you know one of the two right
and they didn't cancel him yep I think
uh you look you look back in time
what they learned the government the
intelligence agencies is that
assassinations are a bad idea
you know it Martyrs people it makes
their their ideas last forever and so
look what look what they're doing to
Julian Assange
you lock them up in a tiny room so he
can't work so he struggles to work you
claim he's crazy you accuse him of being
of bad moral character and then you let
him just wither away effectively killing
him very very slowly but then you don't
get a martyr then they start
manipulating The Narrative and then make
sure as many people as possible hate you
and now they've convinced the younger
generation that Julian's actually a bad
guy so they have these young Democrat
voters who don't like him I think that
is what the left wants to do and I think
that's what they're doing to the January
6th there's a lot of them are in
solitary confinement totally suffering
many of them literally zero violence
walked inside and so on but they just
want to slowly kill them because
solitary confinement does drive people
crazy forcing people to take drugs of
course that's going to make you crazy
that's the goal of the drug to alter
your brain so I I definitely think that
the left doesn't want to make it into a
spectacle because yes then they'll be a
martyr I mean I think in some ways
that's what happened with Trump they
were like we're going to raid Mar-A-Lago
all this stuff they realized oh my gosh
now Trump has more support than ever
everybody is obsessed with Trump trump
2.0 so they're not going to do that to a
lot of these other people they'd rather
just have them slowly wither away
that's the the ubliet is the old torture
well torture chamber it's an old prison
cell French means to forget and they
would just throw people down a hole wow
and then what you just slowly dive
dehydration or they'd pull you out
eventually and put you back in the cell
and be like if you do that again you're
going back in the ubli yet is there
water in the ubliet they would just dump
stuff down there they'd be laying on
like dead rats dead dead human bodies
would be in the with them they'd be
laying there they'd like pour buckets
down jeez they'd defecate all of
themselves I mean it was the worst of
the worst torturous prison cell and
anyone could do it at any time a lot of
a lot of castles have a new but yet and
now you know social media Banning
someone on social media it's kind of
like hopefully they forget about them I
think that's what they do with Trump
they were like now that he's gone his
influence won't be won't be permeating
but they need Trump
yeah they need the boogeyman yeah they
tried doing desantas it didn't work they
tried doing Tucker Tucker is the new
Trump and like no he's really not you
know without Trump but he gives Jennifer
Lawrence nightmares he does yeah I don't
want to think that Donald Trump
resembles like a politic he's just a guy
he's a really unique guy but wasn't
wasn't Jennifer Lawrence's nightmares
that like she was being chased by a bear
and a big manly Tucker Carlson ripped
his shirt off and then fought the bear
off and saved her and then like they
swung from a vine to you know
like she never said the nightmare was
that she was scared of Tucker you know
what I mean like maybe the nightmare was
Joe Biden was coming up behind her and
then Tucker jumps in and saves the day
yeah well she's just trying to get a
sniff you know that's how her family or
like people she knew from her home she's
too old because she's from like Middle
America or Republican and that like
freaks her out to think that any of them
would ever watch Tucker Carlson she's
probably like oh my gosh you guys are
brainwashed and so I think her her whole
goal was to say how you know people who
watch Tucker are basically total idiots
hmm yeah and a lot of people watch them
compared to the Old Guard as he's I I
think he's the number one if I'm wrong
in all of the United States when it
comes to news reporting and you know
he's someone that again also criticized
Donald Trump in many instances called
him out for for a lot of actions but
he's able to to say things that of
course a lot of people can't even say
online so that's another aspect to why
he might be so popular because he's on
television which oddly now is a little
bit more of a free place than the
internet when it comes to online speech
it used to be the inverse of that but
now we have this space where he says a
lot of things that really has your
eyebrows uh rising up but is it because
he's got big money Fox advertising
behind him that Google won't ban there
was a lot of advertisement boycotts
against him uh yeah he lost a ton of
advertisers they're they're still even
on you know when I watch this program
there's still segments where they don't
have any advertisers and they just do
the kind of Fox music so my pillow uh
it's only my pillow yeah some big Pharma
ads and then RV ads I saw on there but
then other than that is just like a
blank screen like hold on we'll be back
with Tucker we should advertise our
Tucker we'll just be like hey you're
watching this show turn it off go to
youtube.com
I think his show is also just so much
better than so many other shows on TV so
if you're going to turn on a show in
that realm I think that's the show to
watch because he has like interesting
content I think so many other people who
have those jobs just don't have
interesting comments you can watch
something all day and it's literally
like the same thing the same story I I
saw him get humiliated by uh Jon Stewart
when he came in with a bow ties a long
time ago and it I gained so much respect
for Tucker having gone through that in
public like being publicly humiliated
and just like eating it and being like
you know I'm not perfect and he would
like address his own weaknesses he
became a way better journalist after
that and willing to listen to opposing
view he's always kind of liked opposing
views but he really became like an
impressive man after he got where he was
by debating and having conversations
with the opposition
all right everybody we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com to become a member one of a
members only show coming up for you at
about 11 pm and if you go to
losingmymind.com
pre-save the new song that's dropping
tomorrow I think it's at 9am
I guess with the team's working on it
but the music video is really really
great I think Ian has the best part in
it and uh you'll see from the image that
it's me in a news desk with a lower with
a Chiron lower third and a picture of a
virus and it says um I think oh no I I
don't want to give away too much but you
get the idea of what we're criticizing
so you'll I don't want to spoil it we've
got some uh individuals that you'll see
in the video that are making an
appearance but legally distinct from
being called a guest I'll put it that
way all right let's read some super
chats
mimic says do not believe the polls vote
like the polls are rigged against you
the polls are wrong you better go out
and vote man yeah we're going to be
we're going to be doing an extended show
here next Tuesday we're gonna be hanging
out we'll have pizza we'll have wings
for a number of days until the election
is right we'll be sent over here could
be a while we'll be we'll be all oily
and tired like we're getting the poop
buckets ready you're not non-stop Luke
there is a bathroom in this room hey are
you gonna drink coffee you want to do it
live be here for that episode you want
to make it real you're gonna miss the
election night
what I think of the election
I'm gonna be so caffeinated
this is where we're coming in and out
they have some multiple guests on the
show I think people will be sitting down
and yeah all right Alex Grant says I
have a question for Luke when you
confronted Lord Jacob Roth's child and
said the New World Order has no
legitimacy and he turns around and looks
at you with no emotion what went through
your mind it gave me chills holy cow
this is happening like holy I waited
outside like four or five hours with my
friends in in win like in the winter in
New York City because we got a tip that
he was there and it was a surreal moment
because that interaction it's one of the
most viewed video that I ever did it's
on my YouTube channel we are changed if
you haven't seen it yet check it out but
uh Lord Jacob Rothschild definitely left
off with a very creepy weird vibe and
that interaction uh was one of the
highlights of my careers uh out of many
highlights but but him he's one of the
you know biggest players out there that
conversation check it out
Sean P says journalists might be illegal
if Republicans win don't threaten us
with a better time polls show the public
don't like journalists he said something
about like historical writers or writing
or something like that this guy was an
MSNBC and he was like they may they may
take your kids and kill them
all right so you said something like
that it's like are you kidding are you
kidding man these people are yeah I
follow the gaming uh the gaming crowd I
watch a lot of Gamers online and one of
the metaphors that's now going around
the Gaming Community is saying that
something is illegal if it's too good or
too like shouldn't be happening you're
like oh there's no way he got me out of
the Bush that's illegal weird metaphor
to start moving around in people's minds
perhaps
an American grizzly bear says hi I'm I'm
a Latino living in Texas just received
Democrat flyers in my mail January 6 in
abortion they really are doubling down
with this till the end never voted
Democrat and never will after this
wow
crazy that's good to hear
all right Jeff Greer says Luke we need a
no amnesty t-shirt
yeah I like that idea too I just posted
a no amnesty meme yeah
grafty says Peck the buck button buck
buck that's right buck buck smash the
like button chickens are great we're big
fans of chickens I think we're getting
new chicken actually a naked neck silky
yeah wow yeah they're touch goofy little
looking things they're great we love
them
Jonah Schmidt says it's my birthday
today I would love if you'd shout out my
original animated TV show who killed Mr
Jones on Kickstarter I decided rather
than complaining about the garbage
Disney puts out I'd make something very
cool man
happy birthday Jonah there you go happy
birthday man
what's the uh so illegal you were saying
illegal is that supposed to be like
you're saying it's so good they're gonna
ban it well the metaphor the way they
use it is like oh they got me man that's
oh that's that's that's that's bad
that's like uh oh that's dirty it should
be allowed yeah that's oh they shouldn't
have done that because the left ruins
everything is their assumption right or
the the powers that be it's like they're
seating people to accept that we're
gonna start making innocuous things
illegal it's really troubling I don't
like that metaphor when something's
legal don't call it illegal
all right Clint Torres says howdy
Danielle I'm a huge fan of your dads and
I've always appreciated the work you do
as well amazing job on filling in for
Dinesh on his show oh well howdy make
sure to find little Dinesh aka me even
though you're a fan of you know the
original
Jacob Jones says great red flood sounds
better than red great flood just rolls
out of the tongue a bit better yep
Democrats need to start building their
Ark because they're going to need it
after this
to survive all of the Republicans coming
out
Samuel Locker says it's said like Locker
Tim LOL just made it in time to early
vote tonight before the polls closed
felt so good to stick it to our Ukraine
sellout house rep by voting for an
independent candidate to take his place
pray for our country
here here man
turret says we need rank Choice voting
that's an interesting thing because
Republicans came out against it recently
what do you think about ranked Choice do
you know any thoughts on it I I don't
I don't know I mean I think the
Democrats do weird things when we have
these like weird rules so for example in
Georgia you can vote in a primary of the
opposite party so Republicans could vote
in Democrat primaries Democrats can vote
in Republican primaries so that's
another reason we didn't get Purdue for
example as the candidate running in
Georgia we got Kemp who was there last
time who obviously was part of how we
got into this huge mess in Georgia so I
don't think that would have happened if
Democrats weren't voting in that so I do
think it becomes a mess when we start
like meddling with you know like you
cast your vote you vote for the person
you want like
put your ballot in that's it I don't
know I just I think that that could get
a little questionable because then
Democrats will start putting our really
good candidates low and then put like
worse candidates higher because they
want ours to be overall lowest so I
don't know I just think it might not be
good Thomas sidebottom says I have gone
through my ballot and looked at people
I'm voting for without looking at their
party went back and looked at party
after out of 17 races only one Democrat
made it into my list
yep
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim hi uh
could you ask Mr Big Mac why he's so
stubborn to see the progress Trump has
given us sure he may not be who we want
him to be but to but a force
nevertheless for good of the for the
good of the nation
definitely a Force for good debatable I
respectfully disagree
okay well I'm gonna make uh some
arguments on the social side because I
know many Libertarians might be
listening but I do think that Trump has
done so much for uh religious freedom
he's done a lot for life I think if it
weren't for him we wouldn't have had Roe
v Wade overturned we wouldn't be in a
situation where we have the Supreme
Court that we do which also ruled on you
know gun rights things like that many
other issues not just those he did bump
stocks
and he said I like to take the guns
first and then go to the courts later
exactly that right there is is a huge
step against the second amendment that
it was even further than Barack Obama
would have done but would you give up
the court in order to take down Trump uh
because I don't play politics I don't I
don't believe in either either of these
criminals to be honestly I don't like
any of these politicians so that's just
my take well I do play politics I guess
but I do think the Court's important
because they're going to influence
things for the next 50 years and so
having a conservative Court like that's
so huge even Beyond just Trump as a
person or something that he said once
what do you think about term limits for
justices but that's still not talking
about the Second Amendment but yeah
anyway I was saying the court did good
things with Second Amendment like things
are changing in New York now the local
state the locals it is good but
Kavanaugh
they they could have issued a ruling
that requiring permits violate Second
Amendment instead they're like no no no
The Government Can require you seek
permission from them in order to bear
arms and I'm just like what are you
kidding me dude no well I wish they were
clones of like Clarence Thomas and Alito
who literally vote right all the time I
wish that too my policy is hey we have
our our issues that we stand behind and
we should always judge a person not on
his political party but what they do I'm
willing to concede Trump did do some
good things and I complimented him when
he did especially when it came to uh
making America First domestically
economically but foreign policy fiscal
policy Second Amendment policy
absolutely disappointing Julian Assange
disappointing he did good things he did
bad things we should treat individuals
individually and hold their feet to the
fire when they do bad I think his
foreign policy was great though because
it was all about peace and I think the
left has become obsessed with
warmongering and the fact that Trump
actually wanted to negotiate and make
the the world more peaceful he said you
know peace is the prize so I think that
was good the people look at the people
yes voting for funding Ukraine the
people in Yemen would disagree
yep far from perfect but better than
Democrats all right
Drew says Tim watched your segment about
Bill Maher and the violent right-wing
rhetoric and I agree with you have you
or would you consider inviting bill on
the show to discuss topics like this and
many others absolutely Bill Maher is
always invited to come on the show I
grew up watching Bill Maher's uh I was a
big fan for a really long time he's
still pretty all right I would say I'm
still a fan of certain respect when he
calls out the whiny Millennial and gen Z
woke lunatics but there's an issue where
he's unwilling to actually do the
research so he has these conversations
where he says something like they went
to a drag Story Hour and like attacked
it or something like hey Bill how about
instead of going on MSNBC and saying
things that are wrong you actually just
Google it and then what would you see
people protested drag queen Story Hour
for underage children and they didn't
attack it but protests got Rowdy because
people are fighting all the time
so you know he wants to talk about how
the Civil War coming when he blames the
right it's like dude
I've been covering this stuff for long
enough I can tell you that the right
never goes outside
you it was it was rare all of a sudden
you started seeing proud boys show up
and I was like wow look at this they're
marching and chanting that's that's new
so uh no dude there were there used to
be a hate hate crime tracker of all the
Trump supporters who were attacked and
there was like a thousand plus incidents
like a guy sitting at a El Pollo Loco
and two guys just grab his hat and throw
a drink in his face like that stuff kept
happening there were the people in a
Cheesecake Factory and got kicked out
because they were wearing Maga hats like
dude
antifa BLM they ride and they cause they
cost billions of dollars of damage torn
on the barricades of the White House
forced the president in a bunker set
fire to St John's Church bro Bill come
on but sure come on sort of attentive
the company they're like the biggest
company in the country on sending texts
for businesses they just dropped me and
my dad for being conservative they were
like we're not going to host you guys
anymore we're not going to send texts
even though it's like a business thing
you know yeah because we have like these
merch stores and they were like we're
done with you so just want to make sure
everybody knows that attentive sucks
um I don't know if I can sue them but I
do think that I can let everybody know
to not use them if you're a Conservative
Business just don't bother maybe try
PostScript or something else but
basically they will have you you know
they'll collect data they'll collect
people's phone numbers and say hey we're
going to text them and so they did that
they've been collecting numbers and
anyways we're going to take the data we
have the numbers but do not use it
what's the company's name attentive
attentive yes just want to make that
known
all right let's grab some super chats
let's see what we got
where are we at
trash Panda says Ian the problem is
people like chenk and the hens on The
View are like Cersei Lannister they
don't respect people like us we are
fleas to them
roaches is what you said roaches yeah
don't worry don't think too much in
terms of us and them and you know they
people react these kind of people that
are like they're emotionally reactive so
as long as you're kind of an emotionally
stable State you can get through it
yeah also and I think something that's
good that we can do is if we can win
over Independence because I feel like
you want to reach out to the other side
and that's great I think we could win
over so many people like focusing on
those eight things you agree on with
someone instead of the one thing that
you disagree on so I do think so many
people will be voting red I also think
it's outside the U.S if you can rally
support of citizens across the world
that's a big part of it
yeah definitely I mean so many people
have family in India all of my dad's
family lives there and they follow
American politics very closely they're
like this is awesome we love Marjorie
Taylor green like they're conservative
but they literally live in another
country where their politics are totally
corrupt and hopefully ours don't become
as bad as other countries even though
it's looking bad but they they
definitely follow like YouTube and all
that stuff the rebellious grizzly bear
says the violence has has been going on
for a long time no one mentions the 2017
Congressional baseball shooting that
almost killed reps scalise the shooter
was a Bernie supporter he was a Bernie
volunteer and scalise still has issues
walking because of the attempted
assassination so uh yeah we talk about
it
Grizzly nightmare says Luke the internet
helped to get us here I agree I think
it's uh it's something that could help
us but also has hindered us because it
has been in the control of very few
people that have made sure that it's
only works in their benefit and not
everyone else's it used to be
decentralized but now with a centralized
Internet it's a dangerous internet yeah
honestly I think it was always it was
always it was arpa it was like
government military technology of course
in the beginning but but in the
beginning we were still able to talk
freely there were still elements of free
speech we don't have that anymore we
have we have algorithms we have curation
instead of message boards instead of
forums instead of real conversations we
have curation yeah I think everything
after using it Daniel C Cronk senior
says I believe that Tulsi threw Biden
her endorsement in the hopes of getting
the VP nod I also think the 25th is too
easy and out for Biden impeach
VP I don't know about that I mean maybe
but I don't know I think she was just
trying to stay influential in the
Democratic party when she came out and
said she's not doing it there were a
bunch of people who were like oh I'm
really disappointed you know because
there are people who are still Democrats
but they're more moderate and so when
she says she's leaving they're like oh
that's terrible you know they didn't
like it
what do we have
Donnie Grant says Scottish guy Alan
Young was in court today for two
separate offenses one is a man one is a
woman hilarious search for Alan Morgan's
Scottish son hurled Pizza really he went
to court two different for that's that's
weird
I wouldn't be surprised man I wouldn't
be surprised
Roger page says Tim they see you as a
conservative because they view
themselves as a Centrist moderate to
them everything to the right is a
die-hard conservative you are correct I
had a guy who's an outright socialist
tell me he's a Centrist and I was like
dude you're a socialist like that's left
of the on the economic scale and the
cultural scale this country is not
socialist and he's like no dude I'm
moderate Bernie Sanders is is you know
slightly left of me and then I'm like
outrights Bernie's a socialist too or
when they say like oh yeah I'm an
independent but every year I voted for
Democrats I'm like oh why are you
independent they're like I think for
myself I'm like oh right okay
blade King says make CNN a Japanese game
show
how much how much money do we need to
buy CNN have you seen that game hole in
the wall that game show where like oh
yeah the wall is moving towards them and
they have to like it's got body shape
yeah shapes of a body so you gotta like
make your body the right shape and if
it's not exactly the right shape the
wall knocks you off right the ledge
fantastic Don Lemon reports the news
while doing that yeah that'd be great
dude I would totally watch them
only don't put no they're not trained
monkeys you know American Gladiators
remember that absolutely oh yeah it's
like Don Lemon and Jake Tapper on there
on that narrow Beam with those big Q-tip
things and they're like or you get to
throw baseballs at them I want to see
that part
well they'd have to run around you have
to beam them with the baseballs I want
to see them enjoying the process yeah
it's gonna be fun everyone has fun all
those are a little Hefty you know no no
no no no not baseball sorry tennis balls
because they had a segment on that show
right where people had to run through
obstacles and they had tennis balls yeah
that's what I'm saying a small cannon
yeah yeah
for sure everyone had fun then they
Gotta Throw tennis balls back at the guy
who's up on the table Yeah to hit the
target yeah could you imagine like Don
lemon's under contract so they're like
the only way we're gonna keep you on we
can't fire him we want him to quit the
audience
we'll each have a fire hose
that they can use as they see fit I
really do like the idea of having a
clicker like a buzzer and if like more
than 35 of the audience hits it you get
slimed or something or pied or dunked
you know because then it's like don't
don't bring up Trump oh and it should be
like half Trump supporters no they would
just be bashing the button the whole
time they would be like ah I do think
there should be a limit like how many
times in an episode can they say how
much they hate Trump like Max is like
maybe 10. I think that's a lot but
literally I don't know if they'd be able
to make it through because the words
probably want to talk about if I was the
boss I'd be like here's how it works you
can say the word Trump
if you say it twice the temperature in
the room goes up one degree if you say
it a third time it goes up two degrees
you say the fourth time it'll go three
degrees and so on and so forth you know
what Whoopi Goldberg does she calls him
you know who like Voldemort like you're
a Harry Potter she's such a child she
actually won't like say Trump she'll
just say you know who I want to see
shock collars and every time they say
Trump
don't take Trump
we know that one too don't try it Trump
has free rent in their brain yeah he
never leaves them
okay let's grab some super chats
Michelle wiggin says hey Tim although I
agree with you at the core without
people who share Ian's thoughts and ways
of attempting communication with others
I fear Society has no hope
yeah I think we need to ostracize cult
leaders
so like
there's there's a question about if you
want to welcome on people like The Young
Turks who willfully lie about our views
for the sake of making money and they do
and they do it often why why do is it I
think it's naive of us to be like why
don't we why don't we have you come on
the show we can talk why so they can
just make up fake stories there's
there's a few people I will never invite
ever again because when I reached out in
good faith they took the story and then
lied and then made it seem like I was
grifting or something and that's their
narrative and then they go on the show
and go here's what happened with Tim
Poole oh man it was a big scam and then
I'm like you know what man I published
the DMS I'm like what was the point of
even trying to invite these people if
they were going to use the opportunity
to just make up a fake story to to smear
me again so I just ignore him I would
also say that that person have hope
because look how many people are waking
up who now have realized that they
cannot keep voting for the things they
used to vote for they've changed their
minds on things so I do think we are
actually reaching a lot of new people
like we have more Hispanics than ever
voting for Republicans more Asians than
ever voting for Republicans Trump had a
lot of um you know blacks voting for him
we have a lot of women I just I do think
we're reaching a lot of new people I
just think that the the crazy people who
who want to kill us aren't the people
are going to convince first but I do
think a lot of like normal people who
actually are interested in making their
lives better we can totally convince
them
disc and balls Golf Channel says Ian
have you considered disc golf as a way
to get outside and get exercise I think
there are probably six plus courses
within 20 minutes of the castle Tim
would you like to have the largest Disc
Golf Channel on Odyssey and Rumble in
your network you'd beat daily wire in
actual Sports shows I mean maybe
eventually I don't know about right now
but disc golf is really awesome and I'm
pretty sure not that far away there's
like you can see the disc golf things
just like they set them up like you go
in the park super cool I bought a bunch
of uh novelty flying discs so that we
could you know throw them oh that's what
those are in the in the living room are
they buy that Super Mario Brothers chess
set yeah I think so
hey they got disc golf yeah I think
that's all this disc golf what is it
going to take Ian what can we do what's
we wait we have disc golf we do have a
disc golf thing whatever it's called we
just never said volleyball let's play
volleyball volleyball yeah if you guys
want to set up a volleyball net I'm 100
let's do it okay yeah I really like it's
just a net and we have we have the back
yard here dude I love them let's do it
do you really what if what if we like in
the middle of the night just you know
put a black bag over Ian's head and
dragged him off to basic training three
months just a drill sergeant screaming
in his face
no but no you can't draft me against
myself you'd come back super ripped just
in three months you know you want you
want people to want to be real we want
you to be healthy so you could stick
around with us Ian yeah yeah you're
getting old yeah yeah but then I'll get
young again my DNA will repair itself
it's all about meditation my man sure
breath breatharians just you know eat
air and sunlight fasting that'll do it
Bryce e says I was debating with a
leftist and said stop simping for the
bourgeoisie they then fled out said
that's GOP propaganda never thought I'd
see the day where you set where saying
that his GOP propaganda I hope they were
trolling no they believe it I've never
heard the GOP say stop simping I don't
think that's GOP propaganda but the idea
that they're working for the elites or
whatever they'll argue they're on a cult
dude that's a that you're in a cult yeah
it's when you come out and you're like
we are the 99 percent and Walmart's
slogan is something I think is important
to everyone it's like okay they're
you're working for the corporations like
Amazon and Walmart love BLM you go out
and March for that yo that's like the
mainstream establishment corporate
narrative
good luck I guess yeah that was the
difference with Jen when she was on here
when we were talking about Amazon and
Jeff Bezos she was like yeah I agree
with you guys I'm like finally we see
eye to eye which is great zorark Graf
says please get Kanye on your show it'll
go viral love you guys but I'm going to
watch The Lex pot with Kanye I missed it
great show tonight yes if it was that
easy just to like
Kanye appears on the show uh Kanye West
would love to have you on the show that
would be great yay West yay West yay
West okay yay at this point just yay
yeah don't know yeah come on the show
it'll be awesome
um and I that's before I'm I don't even
care too much about the the controversy
I'd be more interested in hearing about
like building business yeah you know how
do you go from making music to building
this this Empire and making all this
money all that stuff I think there's a
lot more to talk about that's what he
wants to talk about I mean I don't know
it's what I'd rather talk about it's
like we get it man we've heard the media
doesn't like whatever I don't care and
how did he survive Kim Kardashian I
don't know I just think I just think she
would steal his phone and who knows what
would happen I think she didn't like
that fact that he was a free thinker
she's very image conscious and I think
she wanted him to be silent be someone
she could control so that she could just
be this like big Hollywood person use
him for connections all that stuff he's
also he's also pledging a 30-day verbal
fast and no alcohol and no adult
entertainment fast that's interesting
yeah
you can speak with your thoughts by the
way yeah
Jason Fleck says I want to know if Ian
would give them their coveted amnesty
too
I fully Advocate having compassion for
people that were misled and even pushy
in their having been misled but I I
don't find it cool to push people when
you know that something's amiss or when
you're not like like the people at the
top forgive them for being cruel but
don't forget what happened and do not
let something like this happen again
I don't know forgiveness is like it's an
honest mistake but if you're an
authoritarian there's no mistake yeah so
if you're like you must do this or else
I don't care and you're like hey but
look your data's wrong and say I don't
care I'm an authoritarian so you're
going to do is you're told there's no
forgiveness for that like I I have I
don't know Hitler I never knew Hitler
personally but I could find it in myself
too yeah I didn't know I'm exactly
personally I could find it in myself to
forgive the man for being what he was as
he was a part of a system uh a cruel
horrible system of World War One it
never ended for him yeah and but never
again will that happen and if I was in
charge of the military and I saw a
foreign leader start to invade foreign
countries dude I'd bring the hammer down
I don't know how you say you could
forgive me I feel like you're getting a
little too open-minded
well he was like after World War One
Germany was shredded by the by the
liberal that was before the liberal
economic order but they split off pieces
of Germany and turned it into other
countries and then those countries
governments were abusing and murdering
the German population in the new land so
it was like
yeah he was twisted by the being in the
trenches and getting artillery falling
all around him for months yeah I get it
but you know I'm I oppose the death
penalty but I do have exceptions you
know like there there are limits to even
my decency I don't like I don't like
um death penalty because I don't trust
the US government to adequately
like prove why they should take
someone's life they just don't trust
them and people are like Tim what if
someone like abused kids and I'm like
yeah no no I get it but if like commonly
hair is going to walk up to me and say
trust me you know Ian did this thing I'm
like no no I don't trust you and you're
not going to get me to pull the lever on
somebody else's life it ain't gonna
happen yeah forgiving someone doesn't
mean I'm gonna trust them there are
certain people like Hitler for instance
where I'd be like yes like there's a
chair you know just firing squad
whatever there are there are evil evil
people in this world and that's the
reality is
we fought a war literally knowing that
lots of people would die because what he
was doing was so incredibly wrong and
the scary thing is we didn't learn about
the Holocaust until afterwards
Mao zaitung and Stalin could get it too
yeah true and even going back to covet I
think Kamala Harris I mean she was
basically saying she wouldn't take the
vaccine if it was Trump's vaccine so
this was like totally political politics
like before they knew a thing right so
of course normal people They didn't know
they're just like oh my gosh like we
have a crazy shutdown I'm gonna take
this but I do think the people at the
top Kamala Harris Biden fauci like they
knew exactly what was happening and when
she decided to flip-flop on those things
that was all political yeah I don't like
the lies fauci's working with Eco Health
Alliance to fund research out of the
Wuhan lab and just acted like he wasn't
and I don't know the quotes Luke if you
even remember like did he specifically
say I'm not we were not I was not
funding gain of uh function research but
I was funding a company that was doing
gain of function research and you're
like well the lies I don't like the I
can't I won't I won't forgive lying I
don't but I I don't hate him I mean he's
part of a system the system's disgusting
I don't know you gotta hold people
responsible but my friends if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you at about 11.
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast and there's
one super chat here from Raymond g
Stanley Jr he says guys what you think
Tim records versus Tom McDonald I got a
couple things to say head over to
losingmymind.com
pre-save the new song genocide
parentheses losing my mind bye timcast
it's going up tomorrow I think at about
9 A.M the music video You're Gonna Love
It
it is very political it's extremely
political it's loaded with gags and and
mockery for the machine and the
establishment it's a direct critique of
the institutions and the media and uh we
it is not Tim cast records we had no
idea what we were doing we put out the
first song
um so it's just Tim cast that's just
like basically my stage name essentially
but the record label is now being called
trash House Records because I was
talking to Kent and I was like it it did
the video production and I was like we
need to come up with a name like a good
name for something like trash house or
something like Oh I like that and I was
like okay whatever and then everyone was
like oh yeah yeah trash house that
sounds that sounds good and I'm white oh
okay I guess and I just like literally
pressing on top of my head but that's
what we decided to go with to make it
distinct from me because people were
pointing out correctly like Tim cast is
the music but also the record label and
I was like well I don't know man I
didn't we don't know we're doing but
since we released only ever wanted and
it hit the Billboard charts and did so
well hit number two in sales
um we actually got interest from Big
Industry uh guys who were like yo like
we're going to work with you and we're
going to make this stuff pop and we're
going to do it better so now we've got
more professional industry assistance
with promotion release tracking
distribution all that good stuff and uh
they're helping us get it all set up so
tomorrow at 9am the song is coming up
really excited for it so again losing my
mind.com do you want to shout anything
out Danielle oh uh shout anything out um
go to my website it's Americana so
American and then a by danielle.com and
that's where you can get like my merch
like my Mean Tweets cheap gas tumbler
other things like that you can also get
my books or everything like that signed
and also find me on social media on true
social getter parlor all the places but
you know I'm still on all of the the
corporate ones too what do I want what's
your handle oh I'm at Danielle de Souza
Gill on all the platforms except Twitter
I'm Danielle de Souza G because Max
characters so well thank you so much for
coming on that was a great conversation
my YouTube channel is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I did a very
interesting video today about all the
news happening in Iran Russia Putin
joking about you know a nuclear war lots
of crazy stuff is happening all over the
world I covered it youtube.com forward
slash we are changed the video is up
right now see you there and I would love
to talk about God on the after show
which we often talk about crazy like
hurtful things I want to kind of
understand Consciousness a little bit if
you guys are into that I don't want to
put you on a spot or anything that would
be fun that'd be fun follow me at Ian
crossland.net and you can follow me
anywhere on social media8i and Crossing
love you catch you later and I'm
serious.com see you guys in the comments
losingmymind.com click that pre-save
button because I got my marketing guys
they sent me a screenshot of all the
people who did so far and I'm like we
can do better come on guys support the
song if you really want to help us out
we're um you'll you know what when you
see that when you see the music video I
think then you're gonna be like okay
that's totally worth it so check it out
and we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers